good
morning morning mam Chief welcome to
Edna I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill
1331 and calling representative Mark
PR good morning Madam chairman and the
rest of the committee it is nice to be
back in Edna
again uh this morning I'm coming with a
bill that was requested by one of my
constituents who worked with a person
who is a dentist in another
country uh and now that she's and had
practiced there for some time and now
since she immigrated legally to this
country um she can't use any of her
education well and I take that back a
little bit she is an assistant to a
dentist a dental assistant and that's
about as much as she can do um without
having to go through through the
whole dental school again which is a a
large chunk of money but a lot of time
that maybe
if we could come up with some kind of
program that they can have a special
license under the supervision of a of a
licensed dentist
to maybe utilize those skills better
um and that's why I'm bringing this and
I know you can see the the Bold in the
the bill of the change but I would also
like to add dental offices that um the
dentist signs off on that they're okay
with this person working underneath them
granted we would have to vet them and
and maybe come up with some kind of
program as you know uh especially in our
state the
U shortage of dentists and dental
hygienists and all of that whole uh area
I is pretty high we're always looking uh
for more and it seems like again here in
New Hampshire I know there's a national
uh
certification board that oversees this
but I would like to see if we can't make
it a little bit easier here in New
Hampshire for them to be able to expand
their their abilities and their scope of
practice um so that our citizens will be
better
served uh there's a gentleman from the
uh Dental Board and we're kind of on the
same page and maybe just need some to
work on this a little bit to come up
with
something that will be able to be
helpful and with that I'll end my
testimony and take questions thank you
are there any questions for
representative PR representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair and representative
PR how are you good to see you again
brother
um maybe to help you out a bit uh we've
had this discussions in in the past we
both lived it and that is with EMTs and
reciprocity Y and how that occurs uh
national standards and stuff do you see
any coralation here where any of those
like particular particular models so I I
would I would think there would be some
of that you have to look at where
they're coming from and do they meet our
standards or whatever and I understand
the
uh National Dental Board is kind of
strict on that so maybe we need to work
on them a little bit but uh I'm not sure
how we would do that but yes reciprocity
and and our
licensing um I know I I
a few years ago I had brought something
about dental
hygienist um there was a class uh
there's a school in in Worcester that
does dental
hygiene and this person lived in New
Hampshire wanted to get licensed in New
Hampshire and her friends went to
Massachusetts they were licensed in like
Hours here in New Hampshire it was two
to three weeks or even longer before
they could get the license had to jump
through a bunch of Hoops that down in
Massachusetts didn't have to and I'm
like how did that happen usually we're
supposed to be easier but Massachusetts
is is easier so all those people that
were were kind of thinking about coming
to New Hampshire went to Massachusetts
instead so I think overall we need to
look at that whole board and their
licensing and how we get can get more
people to come to our state instead of
other states um representative PR you
may be interested to know that there was
a performance audit of the Dental Board
I believe two years ago now and they
have made significant progress in
accelerating their licenses so excellent
this this problem had been identified by
a lot of other people representative
laus um
there's problem probably after he's done
if there's somebody here from oplc who
can speak on her I think I have a
question for them that might be
better any other questions for
representative
pro thank you thank you for your
testimony Mr rer
HS such a strange
environment good morning Douglas
osterhout general counsel for
oplc uh I think you're right
representative I think we have made
great strides in
um how fast we can process licenses over
the last few years um one of my points
today I I have a couple of points on
this bill I think there's a little bit
of ambiguity in some of the language the
office doesn't take a position but
there's ambiguity as the term terms such
as limited license um I think there
might be a little bit of redundancy when
you compare this bill to the language of
RSA
317a 20 Roman numeral 3 parentheses B
which provides for students for
commission on Dental
accreditation uh to practice in
hospitals or other institutions based on
the testimony we just heard I'm not sure
if that was the intent but but there is
that uh 22 CFR 62.
22 um also is about the exchange visitor
programs um from individuals educated
from other countries uh and then one of
the main reasons I came up today was
just to point out some of the conflicts
with RSA 310 namely RSA 3104 um this
bill would give the board the ability to
process licenses it's a 655 310 issue um
the same with um I do want to point out
the
one of the big steps we made last year
was in House Bill 594 which created RSA
31017 we talk about this bill a lot I
think representative lakas alluded to it
it's the uh reciprocity and endorsement
bill that gives the oplc the authority
to Draft rules for lure endorsement in
the State uh we have interum rules in
place there is a I believe a public
we've we've submitted an initial
proposal for uh regular Ru making on PLC
313 and we have a public hearing on
March 7th and then we're trying to hope
to get to Jael car by April um and
dentists being a priority were one of
the first 13 boards addressed
in uh the interim
role all right thank you could you tell
say again which RSA describes the
limited license opportunities
the limit well I think that the limited
license term is
ambiguous well excuse me you cited an
RSA that said might be applicable oh oh
I'm okay uh proposed language um RSA
317-a colon
20 Roman numeral 3 parentheses
B and that's the
uh it provides students from the
commission on Dental accreditation
accredited schools to practice in
hospitals or other institution under the
supervision of a faculty member right
that's fine okay uh and then there's the
exchange visitor program that was 22 CFR
section 62.2 two that sounds like a
Federal Regulation that we don't have
much
Authority all right thank you very much
other questions representative laus and
and then O'Brien and then M py thank you
you um so on the proposed Ru making uh
two parts one is is anything in there
addressing uh foreign
dentists and and also uh is there
anything in there about dental
hygienists so when we interpret 31017 it
just says a jurisdiction outside of New
Hampshire we interpret that to mean all
other jurisdictions so whether it's
another state whether it's a foreign
country you would have to meet those
substantially similar requirements so
they might not be specifically addressed
but the requirements would be the same
because they're out of state um dental
hygienist if it's a licensed type it
would be in the
313 thank you O'Brien thank you madam
chair um I would like to go on record as
a dauntless defender of anybody that
goes to our own particular uh
educational to get certified
and everything but I do also support the
reciprocity end of it uh can you give me
like a ballp what your guesstimation
would be I mean is there a void that
needs to be filled with people from
another country that are certified to
come in to do these type of
jobs and I'm not going to hold you to a
particular number I'm looking again a
ballp you know I think anytime there's a
Workforce shortage which we've
identified it's pretty common knowledge
it's nice to get a qualified individual
from anywhere we can get
them
uh I also think for this legislation we
have the mechanisms in place because of
31017 where we can do some rule writing
and make sure we can get those qualified
individuals in the state without
necessarily needing additional
language and follow up if I may Madam
chair in doing
so would that be up to the particular
employer or to the board uh to determine
that in other words would they need a
sponsor uh to know that these people
going to have a uh employment in that
related
field
I think that goes beyond the scope of
what I can answer for
lure okay adequate enough thank you
madam represent man
py thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh two parts with the
licensing
RSA
317-a that you referred to about
alternative
licensing does it have two paths
experience as well as
education or it's just experience
qualified I would I don't have the
language in front of me I would need to
have that language before I could answer
that adequately a followup
follow I
can kind of look at it from the India
perspective the professional education
can happen after 12 years of K through
12 and get into med school or
dentistry in this country you have to
have undergrad so you get short of those
three years and that happened to me in
my profession so there are
educational evaluation ones so has New
Hampshire incorporate there are
designated educational assessment ones
that look at number of hours in the
professional field so that's something I
don't know off the top of my head but if
we look at the initial proposal for PLC
313 we'll be able to see the the
qualifications for somebody from another
jurisdiction coming in and we could get
the answer from there I just without it
in front of me I couldn't answer that
just thank you m representing
broa thank you Madame chair so
um setting aside the fact that we don't
have a limited license we don't have
that defined in
statute and we have conditional licenses
which we created for something similar
to
this um and the fact that the board
doesn't issue licenses any
longer um are we saying that with 3 uh
17 with RSA 317 we have a
enough
um Authority with oplc that they could
that they could review this and possibly
Grant someone a license in this
case or do you want to look at the
RSA yeah I'm I'm looking at it too I'm
just want to know what
he oh RSA
317 I would need to see that so the way
we would do it right now is if an app if
you were licensed in another
jurisdiction and application come in we
would process that license under the PLC
313 the
313 uh RSA 31017 has not withstanding
language so essentially that gave the
executive director in consultation with
the Abo's authority to promulgate rules
regarding Lure by reciprocity or
endorsement so those rules could reflect
37 a20 but without the language in front
of me I I'm kind of hesitant to answer
any questions about it
it okay thank
you if you are looking at that you would
also consider the exemption for a health
care charitable trust because looking at
it it seems to me that such an entity
could set up a not for-profit dental
clinic and hire whomever they
pleased and I'd like to have that
have you look at that if that is in fact
the
case I can take a look at it okay thank
you any other
questions representative Shu are you
asking a
question oh okay in that case thank you
and uh Michael a
corba
thank you madam chair and through you
through the members uh for the record my
name is Michael albach I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Dental
Society on behalf of our nearly 1100
member dentists hygienists assistants
and office staff I'm speaking you today
in opposition to HB
1331 the nhds greatly appreciates the
efforts of rep PR uh to examine an
Innovative approach to our ongoing
Workforce shortage uh New Hampshire is
one of the few states in the Northeast
in which dentists and dental
professionals are seeking to move doing
no small part to our strong economy and
exceptional quality of life however
according to a number of reports we've
received over the last few years uh the
uh the time it takes for dental
professionals to obtain their licenses
uh has made it problematic for dentists
and dental professionals uh move to
Granite State such obstacles only
exacerbate the ongoing uh care shortage
and access to care some uh new patients
have to wait up to a year uh to be seen
by a dentist due to this Workforce
shortage HB 1331 along with many of the
other bills that you've just discussed
um has promise as an Innovative approach
uh there are a number of issues that
this bill as as has previously indicated
there are some issues that uh impact its
viability and Effectiveness if it is
passed as is for example the bill does
not provide criteria for the licenses or
scope of prati address the scope of
practice issues uh that has been
mentioned I believe that working
together with the oplc this body uh the
board of dental examiners and oral
health stakeholders uh these issues can
be addressed down the road the nhds is
working with oplc and the board of
dental examiners to find ways to improve
the current licensing system and there
have been some improvements uh we're
also working with legislators like you
the governor and oral health
stakeholders to find new ways to
to recruit Dental professionals to the
state at the same time we must be
willing to explore Innovative short-term
Solutions until those problems those
longer term problems are
addressed including that which uh refr
proposes here today in light of these
points the nhds uh would recommend that
this bill be placed into interm study uh
so that we can better re examine and
remedy the issues that we just discussed
thank you thank you any further any
questions
representative
Dolan thank you madam chair uh do you
know uh do we have representative Dolan
please don't lean back from your
microphone sorry do you know uh do we
have American dentists who are finding
it difficult to obtain employment in non
us countries that this could be
reciprocity uh fixed for are you aware
of any of those cases uh thank you for
the question I'm not sure if I have the
answer to that I know that currently uh
the American Dental Association is
working with the foresight Institute in
uh Cambridge Massachusetts to create a
broader network of international
dentists and researchers but I don't
know the reciprocity issues going to
other
countries represent man py thank you
madam chair um does this in lack of uh
qualified dentists to practice in New
Hampshire does it tie in with any since
we don't have a dental school in the
state does that bring a big uh
challenge thank you for the question and
that's that's a very uh relevant point
that we do not have a dental school here
in New Hampshire we only have one
training program uh for hygiene and
that's producing uh just a smaller
percentage of the actual uh students
it's supposed to be Gra graduating uh we
do work with the University of New
England as uh sort of a feeder School
New Hampshire residents as well as
Vermont and Maine uh residents would go
to those schools and ideally come back
but as you point out um many of the
professionals who are graduating from
dental school they go on to a residency
and we only have one residency just
brand new here in the State uh which you
know if they go to Boston or someplace
else for a residency they might stay
there so that's a very real concern of
ours okay well let be on the scope of
this bill I believe I believe so yes any
other
questions okay thank you for your
testimony thank you and happy National
Children's Health month all right does
anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill
1331 seeing none I will close the public
[Music]
hearing okay
um going into executive session
representative leus do you have a motion
I do uh itl on 1331 I'll
second all right do you wish to speak to
your motion representative leus I do
um it's I mean I don't think doing this
special case just for Dennis of a new
license type is really the way to go um
you know we need to look
at how well what we've done last year
has worked and if there are specific
problems on uh Dentistry I asked before
we started today I asked representative
PR to send me some details on what the
problems are and um my plan if he did
that was to take them to the oplc
oversight committee and try and get some
answers there and see if it can be
resolved if there is still a problem um
without legislation so thank I think at
this point itl's the best on this
representa yes thank you um I think that
representative luus um address some of
my cons some of my the same points I
would have made and also this bill
really is not reflective of the changes
that we made last year and so for that
reason I agree with the itl
motion anyone else have a comment
question
discussion repr Bailey it was suggested
that perhaps we could do an interim
study I can that we could if we don't do
not vote for the itl we can vote for
interm study but if the Dental
Association is already working with the
oplc to resolve some
issues I'm just as happy to let them
deal with it themselves and let let us
consider what they come up
with
thank you and just following I agree
with that and following on um you know
there is the oplc oversite committee we
can bring it there and raise the issue
and kind of keep an eye on how well what
we did last year uh helps resolve you
know this
problem or the one that led to this bill
okay I'd like to say I'd rather not
create a new license type for very
narrow slice of applic
so I'm I'm stred with this anyone else
representative G I agree Madam chair
with what you just said and especially
um that we have the ability to already
employ these people through the other
mechanisms described all right thank you
represent man py thank you madam chair I
agree there is a lot more to
International uh Ed internationally
educated uh individuals to be licensed
in New Hampshire so this only focuses on
one narrow and I think more
deeper issue of how do
we include or
welcome other outside Educators
different paths would be a more prudent
one and for that I think I agree with
the it thank you right thank you anyone
else repres man thank you madam chair
and we can look at these issues uh
without a vehicle uh as
our without this bill as a vehicle so I
I'm going to vote for the it as well all
right so the motion is inexpedient to
legislate by representative lacus and
the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative Dolan
representative Gart
yes clerk votes yes representative groa
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Shu yes representative
O'Brien yes representative
Davis yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
manuti sorry yes and the chair yes 15 y
z n all right the motion passes 15 to
zero
is there any objection to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
consent and representative leus I'd like
to have the uh committee report prior to
the caucus tomorrow
morning
okay and we have four minutes before our
next hearing at
10:30
so much
room which prefers the other you've lost
some
weight
shouldn't we
all definitely
not I prefer to use the the uh the
units
being it being 10:30 I'm opening the
hearing on House Bill
1222 and I call Representative
roart thank you Adam chair uh members of
the committee I'm my name is David
Rochford I'm representing Grafton one um
in the beautiful town of Littleton New
Hampshire and I come to you with uh a
bill HB
1222 and
um let me grab I think I might have
handed out my notes to somebody oh here
we go uh so first thing I want to I want
to do is is clarify a couple things that
I know have been swirling around that
have caused some consternation and some
worry and uh I just want to kind of set
the record straight here um one thing
that hb1 1222 does if you look at the
act the the title it's relative to
physician assistance scope of practice
and um one of the things if you read the
bill it doesn't really change the scope
of practice Physicians assistants will
still be doing what they do now uh they
won't be doing anything more than what
they do now uh and you know certainly
won't be um practicing outside of what
their current training in so what it
what we really do when you boil the the
bill down is it uh you
know it it C focuses really on the
recordkeeping required for physicians
assistant to to do that the other thing
that's been circling around that I want
to clarify is this bill 100% came from
one of my constituents who happens to be
a physician's assistant you have a
letter there from her uh she would would
have gladly come to this meeting and
testified but the important thing to
realize is that she's booked out two
months ahead of time so she were to
cancel her meetings or or appointments
she's in such demand and there's such a
shortage of primary care providers in
the North Country everywhere in in fact
it would have set her back two months
and she would have had to take these
people who need her and told them that
come back in two months so she wishes
she was here she sent in a letter I I
distributed that letter um for her uh so
you can see the other thing that um the
third thing before we kind of get into
you know more of my testimony is we also
have are asking for an amendment uh as
we as we have submitted the bill my
co-sponsor has been U very um um uh very
helpful in that and what the and that
has been emailed to you we per I forgot
to get the copies to submit to uh um
house committee services to circulate
despite all the other things I gave you
to circulate that was not one of them
but when if you check your email you'll
see that it's uh Amendment um 20250
0454 um it is it has been circulated I
think did we get a copy we've we've got
some copies I think M Clayman is going
to bring out hard copies to distribute
to the
committee so at at the Crux of the
amendment it really defines what
collaboration is and redefines it and
you know the the the definition on the
books right now collaboration means a
physician's assistance consultation with
or referral to an appropriate physician
other or other health care professional
this then changes that to collaboration
means a physician's assistant
consultation with or referral to the
appropriate member of The healthc Care
team when reality it's it's really
that's who that's who physicians
assistant should be referring to if
there's a if there's a question of
consultation it should be the most
appropriate member of The healthc Care
team um and and that may not be a
physician um which we're going to get
I'm going to get into a little bit
further uh the other thing that the
amendment does is you if you look down
on there uh page one lines 19 through 24
it really defines the criteria uh of of
Licensing lure for those traveling
Physicians or Physicians working within
the VA medical system uh and it requires
a collaboration with a uh um someone
within the state now I felt like this is
not necessary and uh for the in the
committee can certainly talk this up but
but remember as we recall last year um
we passed a bill the governor signed it
that increased the portability of
license sure uh around the country so a
a a healthcare provider who holds a
license in another state can get a
license in New Hampshire um relatively
easy as long as the qualifications uh
for lure are similar and I and I've
circulated the qualifications for
licensure and the materials that I sent
um and then the change in line 28 of
that page again is more uh along along
those lines so that's the amendment that
you have before it just kind of gives a
little more completeness to the bill um
and and again this bill was came the the
Genesis of this bill was a constituent a
constituent that has a practice a very
busy practice obviously in the North
Country uh she's a physician's assistant
a long-standing physician's assistant
and uh it came to the point where uh she
had a collaborative as as the law states
now uh Physicians assistants have to
have a collaborative practice agreement
with a a physician and if you look at at
the law there's nothing more than that
that's required than a signature on a
piece of paper um you know this the law
the state does a very good job
separating liability from that
supervising physician so so the
physician's assistant is still
responsible legally um but at the end of
the day they have to get that signature
and it sounds simple that we have a
signature but in many cases this
signature just putting a name on a piece
of paper is costing $1,000 a month
upward of $1,000 doll a month just to
put a name on a piece of paper to
accommodate the law for Physicians
assistants to do what they're trained to
do for them to take the legal liability
completely take the legal liability but
we have this little little part of our
law that says a signature has to be uh
on a piece of paper so this removes that
this allows Physicians assistants to
practice within their scope to practice
within their training to see patients
and to see uh uh to treat members of the
community and that's of a particular
concern in urgency right now because
there's a drastic shortage of primary
care providers it wasn't only a year and
a half ago where we saw headlines uh
where the largest Health Care system in
the state of New Hampshire was no longer
taking Primary Care patients they were
maxed out they were full they didn't
have enough providers to take care of
the people in this area with the without
mentioning names I mean it's a it treats
it treats a lot of people in the state
of New Hampshire so we've talked about
you know I I've circulated some
information about training uh a phys I
looked at the in the concern are they do
they have adequate training to do this
again this is just removing a signature
on a piece of paper the state already
says they have adequate training but
just to put it into perspective
Physicians assistance right down the
road at Massachusetts College of
Pharmacy and Health Sciences you can go
online and look at it there's a
comparison of their training Physicians
assistance training versus other types
of mid-level practitioner Physicians
assistants have 111 hours of class time
training plus a residency clinical
residency um other mid-level
practitioners have much less than that
um other states are doing this removing
this requirement for collaboration
Wyoming Utah North Dakota are leading
leading the way um I was I was really
tried to find is there any increase in
safety is there any increase in Risk to
the patient and the public there's been
nothing reported there's not a dramatic
increase of uh of of of Adverse Events
in these states um the other thing I
want to point out is we have I believe
we have two schools in New Hampshire
that are uh graduating physicians
assistant program graduating students
from the Physicians assistance program
you you add that with the dramatic need
we have for Primary Care uh providers
think about just South of the Border in
Massachusetts they have a much more
generous and much more open ability for
these mid-level practitioners to
practice so we're losing these graduates
across across the border these are all
people that could be treating people in
New Hampshire by by enacting this bill
h1222 it's my thought uh in even you
know some off off the record
conversations with people from these
schools that that would be a a a an
ability to retain some of these folks in
New Hampshire make it more attractive to
set up a practice in New Hampshire to to
treat people in New Hampshire
um and I'm going I'm going to talk about
two more things then I'm going to then
I'm going to shut my mouth one of the
things that we always want to talk about
is unfounded fears and I I I implore the
committee to really dig into some of
these unfounded fears you know my
profession I'm a pharmacist and a number
of years ago uh we were here in front of
this committee talking about
pharmacist's ability to give flu shots
of all things and uh there were a lot of
people that showed up and talked about
how this is a horrible thing for the
community that the that the pharmacists
were going to give flu shots and it's
going to be so dangerous and they don't
have the training they're not
appropriate for it but now you look at
fast forward just a few years later
pharmacists give more vaccines than
anyone and as a member of the Board of
Pharmacy in my seven years we've had one
complaint of an adverse event with a
pharmacist uh giving a flu shot so
really I I implore the committee to dig
into the fears um really parse out is
this a genuine vetted evidence-based
fear or is a Turf War because I think
some of the things that we might hear
after are concerns about a Turf War and
I implore the committee to to to to
Really press into uh the fears is it is
it a founded fear because again I I I
looked I I tried to find some data that
would justify that and maybe it's out
there and maybe I looked at the wrong
place but I just couldn't find it so um
with that I'm going to I'll ask
questions my co-sponsor is here and uh I
know that he'd like to speak on this
topic as
well thank you repres we do have a few
questions rep representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair uh first
question uh Dr oser uh is um where is
that up to
th000 a month where's that
go well so this came to me from a person
who is close to this they're close to
the physician's assistant in this
particular circumstance um this was a
physician located in Pennsylvania but
through the compact licensing agreements
that we have with other states um the
physician in Pennsylvania could obtain a
phys a license in New Hampshire so
therefore they could qualify under the
law that that that that they did that
and to my knowledge this was a per a
revenue source for this
individual kind of a unique business
model so uh that's yeah that's that's
how it was related to me thank you
followup follow up so uh as you know uh
Advanced nurse practitioners are doing a
lot of medical work uh in New Hampshire
already uh would you say that Physicians
assistants are very comply trained with
Advanced nurse
arpn um uh with regard to their
usefulness in the thing I've been
treated by arpn on a number of in
occasions great results they knew
exactly what they were doing I got
exactly the treatment I needed and so
forth so I'm fine with that especially
since we have a a need how are the
Physicians assistants whom I've also
experienced several times uh how are
they in terms of training comparable yes
thank you for the question um so like
you I'm a big supporter of Physicians uh
nurse practitioners my daughter's a
nurse uh my wife's primary care provider
is a nurse practitioner my wife actually
has a complex heart condition that the
nurse practitioner handles uh quite
adequately um you know I think it's
important to realize what Physicians
assistants are doing now in this state
uh my young my middle daughter the first
day of school or freshman year she
trained all summer long for soccer to
try out for the varsity soccer team um
her first day of school her freshman
year she br broke her foot and uh we
went to the we went to the orthopedic
center we never saw a physician but we
saw a physician's assistant and this
physician assistant really put a very
good personalized care plan together um
we saw her every week uh we had some
therapy all coordinated by the
physician's assistant uh you know my
daughter wasn't supposed to be able to
get back on her foot loadbearing until
Thanksgiving uh through the care that
she got from the physician's assistant
she played in the last soccer game of
the year uh which is a playoff game so
you know as far as care goes I
personally would I do trust my family to
care of both nurse practitioners and
Physicians assistants um you know one of
the things that I gave you and and I'm
not putting down nurse practitioner
again my my daughter's a nurse but you
know when when you start looking at the
data and you start looking at really
founded fears versus unfounded fears one
of the concern one of the things that we
brought up is you know um and you have
this while nurse practitioners May
obtained 500 to 700 hours of experience
in clinical learning about diagnostic
techniques common medical procedures and
case managers Physicians assistants are
required to spend almost 2,000 hours in
clinical environment prior to licensing
so I mean there's not a you know it's is
the training model is different actually
in fact the training model for
Physicians assistants MIM mimics as I
understand Physicians um so I I I I
think that we're you know again I going
back to personally I would personally
you know feel very comfortable uh with
either mid-level practitioner for
treatment with my
family representive
Shu thank you madam chair um I see um
the language particularly in the
amendment talks about um previously the
part that's scratched out says
appropriate
physician uh for referral and it just
changes the language to the appropriate
member of the health care team but I
don't see any definition of what that
appropriate refers
to well I think I'd go back to the
original scratched out part I mean
appropriate was is in the law now um so
that is that is defined in the law and I
would imagine that and again I'm I'm I'm
I'm imagining that it's probably you
know these these practitioners these
licensed IND individuals report to
licensing boards and the licensing
boards um uh examine standard of care
and what's appropriate for practice uh
you know it's it's it's not defined in
law I believe in this case but I think
it's referred back to the the licensing
boards the jury of their peers if they
will to determine what's appropriate and
what's not and if you look at that you
know the changing from appropriate
physician or other healthc care
professional to the appropriate member
of the healthcare team really reflects
the the the evolution that we've
experienced in healthc care uh over the
last 30 or 40 years you know for
instance you know my own profession as a
pharmacist if we're dosing you know if
if if a provider be a physician's
assistant or even a physician needs to
dose an I apologize for the technical
terms but an aminoglycoside antibiotic
the appropriate member of the healthcare
team to to to figure out the dosing of
that isn't physician it would be a a
pharmacist a clinical pharmacist in that
point um yeah absolutely and my
co-sponsor can add to that uh I'd like
to pick up on that I'm representative
Jess Edwards representing Rockingham
District 31 I'm happy to be a co-sponsor
of this bill uh to to try to uh answer
your your question with a little more
legal
specificity uh This this term to the
appropriate member of The healthc Care
team really establishes in the law uh
the obligation of the PA to do what the
pa would normally do and that is to
manage the care of the patient and to re
make the referrals
necessary uh historically because of the
collaborative agreement the term
physician had been hardwired into the
law because the PA would would be
subjected or uh sub yeah subjected to
the authority and discretion of the
physician what this is doing because
we're moving more into an independent
practice and freeing the PA up from the
collaborative agreement
ties what we're what what this does is
it essentially
establishes um the um the uh the kind of
the
malpractice law so that if a PA
mismanages a patient and does not do a
proper referral to say a
dermatologist to a Cardiologist to you
know whoever is in the integrated
healthc care team if the PA doesn't do
that right and there's harm to the
patient this language is basically the
umbrella that uh that they can be held
accountable
under also this language came from a PA
this came from um what what what what we
did was after we did the the the
original Bill we continued to staff it
and get additional input and so we we we
ended up with a very senior PA who um
who pointed out that tying the PA to The
Physician would no longer be the right
way to go that it would be better to to
to create the relationship in law to the
healthcare
team and followup question um I also so
see um on the original Bill line 15 phys
assistants are solely responsible for
the care they
provide um do they have access to the
same malpractice insurance that
Physicians have or what is that
situation there's someone like a later
speaker will says he's an able to answer
that question properly yeah so so the
the short answer is the PA when working
under a collaborative agreement is also
subjected to the malpractice
insurance of the physician that's
responsible for the care because we're
reestablishing the
relationship the PA would need to go
obtain their own
full Med malpractice
insurance what what with this with this
what the big concept here is is that uh
since nurse practitioners and PAs were
established in the late 60s early 70s uh
they have sort of developed in on
Parallel paths and in different states
the autonomy of one relative to the
other has varied like in the in Nebraska
physician assistants were extremely
autonomous rather quickly because of the
rural nature of Nebraska and the needs
there and nurse practi practitioners
tended to stay in the heavy clinical
environments um like the medical centers
and and so the characteristics between
these two professions varies by the
culture of the state in New Hampshire uh
what we've had is the nurse
practitioners have done a better job I
think at working the legislature to get
the autonomy and the scope of practice
Freedom that Pas have not and so this is
really an effort to uh make these two
professions equivalent and they really
are from an academic and clinical
perspective um and to create more
flexibility in our health care System to
help address some of the underlying
problems we're having with
Manpower thank you representative maputi
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my
question
Pas can practice independently have a
private practice whereas or sorry the
other way around AR aprns can have a
private practice independently practice
whereas PA still need to be under an
umbrella which carries the malpractice
and liability
correct mostly yes I mean PA still have
to have their own liability insurance
even today right now um but yes uh nurse
practitioners can
freely set up practice move around the
state uh you know whereas Pas are always
tied at least by paper to an overseeing
physician uh
yes thank you other questions represent
Gould thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my
question one one of your statements that
really stood out for me was turf wars
and just quickly and and also
representative Edwards your talk about
um unique cultures in various States and
I'm aware in my research for I'm a
genealogist and I was writing a book and
there was a family that lived in
Claremont and Bradford New Hampshire the
father was the product of a mixed
marriage of a revolutionary war soldier
that came over from England and married
an iroy woman and they bore a child so
they went back to England she died the
boy was raised by his English parents
and went to the finest schools and was
trained as a doctor came back to the
States and decided to go to his iroy
parents uh Mother's um tribe and learn
the medicine of the native people he
bore five children he he practiced both
forms of medicine he bore five children
four sons and one daughter they all
practiced medicine they were all
licensed Physicians including his
daughter in the late 18 early
1900s the three doctors practicing in
clam Newbury and Bradford New Hampshire
practiced both types Patients Preferred
to go to both the the uh a professional
association for physicians in Boston
brought suit against them to stop them
from being able to practice native
medicine and lost and it was a Turf War
it was strictly a Turf War it didn't win
then it's the culture of New Hampshire
how do you find the turf war playing out
in this situation thank you
thank you for the question you want yeah
go
ahead so I'm a little older from a
legislative background I was on HHS EA
on my first committee uh four terms ago
and um uh we saw then in bills trying to
introduce um um different types of
Health Care providers that the
constituencies of the Physicians and the
nurse practition partitioners and the
like uh uh came out and um uh opposed
legislation that allowed uh an you know
Affiliated and Associated health care
provider Community to to get more
autonomy there's there's I think I think
we have a history here in the
legislature of opposition and most of it
is is is well intentioned we're trying
to protect the safety that's why we do
all of this right um but you know I
think if we were to take a look at it
from a slightly different perspective
sometimes what you see is the use of Law
and restrictions as as potential
barriers to entry and the kind of the
protection of of of of of turf it's it's
probably there's probably better terms
but but that's really kind of what it is
sometimes and I don't know who's going
to oppose this bill um and I don't want
to speakers that are going to present
yeah testimony and opposition yeah um
but I but I do think it's time for us to
make equivalent Health Care professions
equivalent functionally in law so that
we can increase the flexibility in our
health care System to meet some of our
needs thank you and thank you madam
chair represent
Gart thank you madam chair is it POS
possible for the public to know about
complaints filed against physician
assistants as well as doctors are they
on equal par with the knowledge of you
know what I mean is there easy ability
to look up adverse um customer
complaints as it were yeah that would be
a question for the Board of Medicine
that's where that that's where that lies
um you know and and I know that you know
I'm on a different board we have a
different way as as you know there
there's been some questions on how those
are handled over there uh so I don't
have an answer for you on that I don't I
don't know the answer to that thank you
representative laus just Mr El indicated
he has can answer that so fine we will
uh call him when when do any other
questions for the
legislators seeing none thank you very
much Nick P
penovich email
FEA
I don't recall it specifically in regard
to this
bill no you have to turn the mic
on how's that okay much better um thank
you uh my name is uh Nick penovich I'm
um retired semi-retired uh General and
vascular surgeon practi RAC and
conquered for 25 some years um I still
interact with medical students at
Dartmouth I teach pretty much every
other day in conquered and up up in
Lebanon and I also interact a lot with
Pas and nurse practitioners at least in
conquered I'm a surgeon so the students
I'm teaching are Dartmouth students who
in their third year taking their core
rotation so they come to conquer they've
been coming to conquered for about 14
years and uh it's mostly didactic
teaching bedside teaching but to make it
happen I deal with Pas and I deal with
nurse practitioners who work within the
hospital setting and uh prior to that
when I quit operating in
2013 um for a good decade I had nurse
practitioners and PAs mostly Pas working
on the surgical service they are both
invaluable resources it was mentioned by
the sponsors and I learned a lot from
the sponsors uh I thought both their
presentations were excellent um I've
learned that they are really incredible
L important yes PA got started about
1965 it was a Duke Duke Medical Center I
guess the hospital maybe the med school
created the idea and for over 50 years
we've had uh pas in the state and
there's no question they do an amazing
job when I do my job now I'm contacting
them always trying to find the best
patience for teaching I get more
information from that than I get from my
former surgical colleagues beyond the
doubt um I'm opposed to this bill
mainly because I don't want to restrict
what they do because what they do is
terrific and I'm not I'm not worried
about them going into an operating room
and starting their own operating rooms I
I don't think that's going to happen I
don't think they want that to happen by
the way the most popular PA when Pas
decide what area of medicine they're
going into the most popular one is
surgery and and and the fact that I get
the interact with them I understand
they're pretty happy group despite being
on night call and so
forth uh the main reason I'm opposing
this is from another part of my past
history so
um in 20120 I was in 2000 I was
president of medical staff at conquered
hospital and there were some things that
we wanted to do from the stpoint of
self-help for doctors that we needed
cleared with the Board of Medicine and
let's put it this way it took me about
17 years to get off the Board of
Medicine I went off in 2019 so I had
various jobs there member of the board
medical of the former medical review
subcommittee for about 25 years we've
had a physician investigator that
disappeared with the medical review
commit last summer but um I got to see
how the board work and U one of the
representatives asked a question can you
know um just recently can you know about
complaints against Pas and the answer is
U any complaint claim or lawsuit whether
it's a PA or MD the Board of Medicine is
MDS dos who we consider in this state
the same and Physicians assistance and
they've been there for 50 years with the
do's and the MDS and the main reason
that is is because they've always had a
supervising that was the term physician
and a collaborative physician it wasn't
a team at that point it was an
individual name it's still is as far as
I know again I went off the board in
2019 four or five years ago um so when
complaints came in they often had the
PA's name sometimes the supervising
position wasn't there lawsuits were a
little more sophisticated an attorney
would dig up and find out from the board
who the supervising Physicians was so
that claimer lawsuit often had both
names on it and then an investigation
would happen and that complaint lwuit an
information that the board got didn't
didn't go public that there was a
complaint in but it did go public if
there was ever discipline of any kind so
there's plenty of information from the
board about what what went to
discipline um if a complaint or lawsuit
was um a settlement a settlement
happened uh let's say it was a hospital
PA with a supervising phys that didn't
go to the board um at all and I don't
think still does but may in the future
some states do require settlement
information to
go um
so all those years I was on the board um
and there was always a PA member on the
board and there still is um we would
hunt down the supervising position to
get their response and sometimes that
supervising position knew nothing about
the complaint they weren't around they
were out of town and the alternate might
have been out of town too but that group
that that physician worked for and it
was usually a group um someone stood up
and you could look at the records and
see that there was someone on call who
took over so the typical example of that
was if you go to any emergency room in
this state you're going to often see a
PA more than a nurse
practitioner and that that PA when that
that patient was interacted with you
could dig out and see who was in that
emergency room as an MD or do so that
name came up and that game came up to be
reviewed by the board when an
investigation happened and that's the
name that the malpractice attorneys
would dig up so that's the system that
we have now so hearing this today it
sounds like um I'm not sure there's
going to be a usual a name there there's
going to be you know a team there and
then how does that happen and yes I know
that Pas have their own malpractice but
if you're a malpractice attorney and you
think something bad's happened you want
to have that Physician's name on it
because they have the deeper pocket and
if that phys disappears if that's what
this committee is going to do make it a
collaborative thing without a name um I
suspect the PA's um malpractice
insurance will go way up I would suspect
I don't
know or do they really need to be at the
Board of Medicine the main reason
they've been on the Board of Medicine
for 50 years that they've had the hab of
supervising in an alternative position
so if we're not going to have a name
there I guess Pennsylvania thousand
bucks to get your name there it's a
business I I've never saw that happen in
my 17 years there weren't Pas
complaining that they had to pay a th000
bucks to get a name on there
particularly from another state how do
you supervise from another state I don't
understand that so I've learned a lot
but I worry a lot and I think if this
passes maybe uh maybe the Pas need the
their own
board um you know that may be the answer
because the Board of Medicine would have
no role anymore if you don't have to
have a PA or alternate
physician any questions for me I I love
I love working with them and nurse
practitioners uh nurse practitioners in
an outpatient setting are kind of a
different animal but that's not the
subject
today thank you madam chair um you had
mentioned that you thought maybe um
Physicians assistants would need their
own board if something like this were to
go through do I would hope do nurse
practitioners have their own
board under the Board of Nursing yes
okay so they're all under the Board of
Nursing and I don't know if there's
separate categories at the time I left
in 2019 there was not it was all gone
the bard of nursing so if there was any
complaint uh whether it was a nurse
practitioner Advanced nurse practitioner
a plain nurse it all went to the Board
of Nursing and they had a very different
structure than we did we had this huge
investigative committee which they never
had thank
you other
questions thank you for your testimony
oh representative Manti sorry thank you
madam chair quickly in terms of medical
board who are under Medical Board Pas uh
so there there's there's a bill out
there to change that and we won't get
into that but the current board has I
believe 11 members it has one doctor of
osteopathy do it has a PA it has three
public members I think they've had
trouble for many years getting three but
that's what's officiated three public
members then there's a design of the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services um who's usually a physician
working in that department who sits on
the board and then the rest are MDS
basically and the MDS on the Board of
Medicine don't have to be in Specialties
different Specialties they can be in the
same specialty when medical review sub
committee which started in the mid 80s
and ended this year that was that was
about 11 or 12 people and it was also
very specifically picked for Specialties
that we had the most complaints and
lawsuits and claims about so we could do
our own investigation without extra
expense to the
state thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you David
czy
uh Madam chair I did email in testimony
did that was that received by the
committee or should I pass out the
copies I brought if you brought copies
we'll take them and recycle them for
you no sense you carrying them back to
your
office it's the Board of Nursing deals
with everything from an LNA to
an
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
David czy with Prospect Hill strategies
here this morning on on behalf of the
New Hampshire Society of physician
assistants also known as dispa I
appreciate the opportunity to make some
comments this morning uh I'll I'll
confess UPF front this is a little
awkward uh as a lobbyist uh and really
on for nispa uh to be here testifying on
a bill that as representative roord uh
alluded to was not our idea if you will
uh so in fact I hadn't I had only spoken
with representative Rochford once before
I saw this LSR pop in the fall and that
was at White Mountain paper and I can
assure you that we weren't talking about
pa uh collaboration agreements at White
Mountain paper and in gorum uh that day
um but but nonetheless here we are as I
understand it there was a uh and as he
explained there was a pa uh from his
district who spoke with him about this
uh the PA is not
to my knowledge affil at least certainly
not on the board of nispa I don't know
if if I think he said it was a a woman
is a member um and so we haven't lobbied
on this bill but nonetheless we're
having the discussion and here we are
today Madam chair and I'm happy to
provide some comments which I think May
clarify some of which some of what you
heard uh earlier so there are uh over a
thousand Pas here in New Hampshire uh
they work in every healthc care setting
uh and I think you've heard that if it's
in primary care emergency rooms surgical
centers uh and every specialty and subsp
specialy that that you can imagine um
and there are two PA schools one at the
mass College of Pharmacy the other at
Franklin Pierce University
um if I may Madam chair just a brief
history on maybe some of the legislative
Evolution legislative and Regulatory
evolution of PA practice a scope of
practice so uh as the previous speaker
alluded to when this profession started
I think and this is where the name came
from physician assistant and it's now
become a misnomer um they were
assistants to Physicians and so they
were uh they were supervised and that's
I think where that term came from but as
time has gone on and I think we all in
this room have seen uh pas are not
supervised anymore in a modern
Healthcare setting it's not like they're
a new server at a restaurant where you
have the manager following that new
server around everywhere they go uh
that's just not how it works they
practice
independently uh they see patients
without anyone looking over their
shoulder they Direct Care they prescribe
meds Etc without any
supervision um we changed and to to
reflect the reality of modern Healthcare
teams uh this committee uh worked on a
bill two two years ago it was Senate
Bill 228 many of you were on the
committee at that time some of you
weren't but the brief history was the
goal of that Bill and that was supported
uh with and we appreciated that uh by
the medical society because it really
was just designed to um make sure our
statutes and now our regulations with
the revised Med 600 rules uh reflected
reality the reality of modern Healthcare
teams and we heard a little bit about
that prior so the law removed the term
supervisory or supervisor it took that
it took that concept out of Statute and
out of regulations because Pas are not
supervised um and it changed and so we
heard the reference to the RSP this
responsible supervisory physician form
that was just a piece of paper that a
physician had to sign and at the time
send into oplc where it sat in a file
cabinet um so the the thought was we
don't really that's that terminology is
unnecessary so what 22 what Senate Bill
228 did was it said it's really a
collaboration agreement because all
members of a healthcare team collaborate
with one another uh as you heard the
previous speaker said he's a physician
he would often collaborate with Pas uh
when when appropriate and that's the
that's the training it's also the ethics
involved in those who practice medicine
is you always get help you always ask
questions uh and so that could be a PA
to a respiratory therapist it could be a
PA to a physician it could be any member
of a healthcare team speaking with
another member of the healthcare team it
could be physician to physician
if it's in the o or any other place a
primary care physician may need to speak
with a a specialist that happens all the
time it's common and it's it's you know
it's frankly required
um so Senate Bill 228 changed they
decided the concept of was to come up
with a collaboration agreement rather
than this responsible supervisory form
so it got rid of
supervisory in the collaboration
agreement the statute and I I do have a
copy of the specific um section of uh
328d that lays out the uh the
requirements of a collaboration
agreement but it states very clearly
that a PA must practice as one might
expect just like any other health care
provider within their training their
education and their experience and that
they always must collaborate with um the
uh appropriate I guess this amendment
said but a physician or other
appropriate member of the healthcare uh
Team I had not seen this amendment till
this morning so I'm not prepared to
comment on it um and that but the one
important difference and this is what
why we're here as why representative
rord brought the bill is
that that collaboration agreement still
needs to be signed by a physician a
licensed New Hampshire
physician now nurse practitioners the
and you know APRN the other mid-level
providers Pas are also mid-level
providers they don't have to have a
collaboration agreement they don't have
to have a a document signed by a
physician for them to practice medicine
uh pas do and that I think is Legacy
because back in the day if you will Pas
were supervised so we're kind of at a
point now where as uh representative
Edwards mentioned where it's a question
now of equity
um Pas have uh roughly and and in the
information I handed out and I I believe
representative Rochford mentioned this
uh in New Hampshire if I and I you know
I'm just the lobbyist so if I'm
incorrect I apologize and I'll I'll
correct any mistakes that I make or
others behind me
will
um NPS after 600 clinical hours can um
Can Begin practicing medicine uh and I
and in theory they can hang their own
shingle and begin you know their own
primary care practice or whatnot I don't
know that really happens very often at
all but it could Pas however uh they
have 2,000 clinical hours before they
graduate from their pa school so that's
three and a half times more yet uh for
the entirety of their career they could
be 30 years into a career they still
have to have a piece of paper with a
signature on it from a doctor that
allows them to be able to practice
medicine
um and again repres resulting excuse me
reflecting current medical team care and
and Health Care provision uh within a
health system or a primary care practice
that
signature only states that the or the
law only states that it has to be signed
by a person who's affiliated with that
practice so these folks these doctors
can sign this it could be a doctor up in
Lebanon at Dartmouth Hitchcock signing a
a bunch of these collaboration
agreements for Pas who work all over the
state the PA never may never see that
person before before or after that
document is signed but the law says that
they have to be when they're practicing
there have there has to be a
physician uh part of that team who is
also available either in person or by
electronic means for consultation so it
can be and that's how a real team
functions so it's really just a piece of
paper that doctor I think a previous
speaker said that doctor could be in
Aruba on a beach you sign that piece of
paper but the PA can't be practic iing
medicine unless that unless there is a
physician available for consultation the
law says they have to consult and that's
reasonable uh the law wouldn't even need
to say that it happens all the time
anyways so we heard a prior speaker I
think a lot of the reasons why um and I
I I shouldn't attribute any remarks to
anyone as I understand it Physicians are
paid often are paid get extra
compensation for signing a collaboration
agreement for a PA like for their
employer the employer goes hey can you
sign this but they might they might be
paid they're they are likely paid
several thousand dollars more a year
just by putting the signature on that
document um that's just you know I would
respectfully suggest that's one could
say maybe Money for Nothing um we heard
now that's not all practices um I as I
understand it may be convenient MD they
don't pay their docs extra to sign yes
ma'am so on the issue of malpractice
insurance we heard that come up I think
one of the reasons why PE why doctors
are paid more is because now that it
does subject them to lawsuit because now
their their name is on this
collaboration agreement what Senate Bill
228 did was it made clear that a doctor
is not
liable uh for the care that a PA
provides uh solely because their name is
on that collaboration agreement so that
doctor who signed that collaboration
agreement who's in AR Ruba of course had
nothing to do with the care of the
patient that is maybe bringing some sort
of an action um now that doesn't mean
they still can't be included in the
lawsuit but now there's some protection
uh of course if that doctor was present
there or any doctor any member of the
healthcare team to your question
provided care of any kind or you know I
I would think maybe is in the building
of course they're going to be wrapped up
in that lawsuit that doesn't change and
the other thing that doesn't change here
if I didn't make this point earlier and
I apologize is that the scope of
practice for PAs will not change I think
representative Roser alluded to that
nothing changes it's just about does a
PA need a piece of paper with a
physician signature on it that they may
never meet the situation described in
and uh with the Pennsylvania physician
there that's a compact doctor and as I
understand it a physician physician
assistants who can own their own
practices but they still need to have
this piece of paper
signed they can there are Physicians who
are in compact States who will sign
these and they charge not $11,000 it
could be up to $11,000 a month that was
the number given to us is thousand a
month yes and so and and I'm this is
what I've been been told uh by uh you
know through nispa so that's a real
number that's a barriered entry of
course Pas are more expensive to hire to
employers than npes because they have to
pay doctors more uh it's a it's a and so
I know Massachusetts there's a law that
would um give partial as a path to full
independent practice uh they they have a
with a two after 2,000 hours of practice
once you're out of school um and so
that's just to the sth of us and of
course we all know that that's really
where the drain is for a lot of the
healthc Care Professionals is is to
Massachusetts and I apologize for uh
going over my time Madam chair and I'm
happy to take questions representative
broa has a
question thank you so this collaboration
agreement do we have um can we get a
copy of that is that a uniform document
it is not a uniform document um it the
law specifically says here's what it
must say and I I if with the chair's
indulging I I could read it um but I
believe it's
328d we can find it up we can look it up
ourselves but there is a there are
stipulate it does have a it's some place
defined what this piece of paper says
correct it yes it must say I I and I
don't mean to be Tri Madam chair but I
guess it's really a name rank and serial
number um and then pract
employers or the parties who are signing
this document can add as much as they
want to it but the law says it must say
these things and then it's kept on file
at the place of employment so it no
longer even goes to the Board of
Medicine but it must be produced on
demand if there were an investigation by
the Board of Medicine as the prior
speaker had had laid out could you
please quote the RSA so I you said it so
quickly I didn't hear it yeah let me
just I want I have it here in front of
me and I I want to give it the right
it's uh RSA
328d colon
3-b thank you thank you thank you other
questions represent vas yeah uh very
very briefly if you if you know uh do
you have any reason to believe that if
we got rid of the requirement for that
signed collaboration agreement if the uh
PA's medical insurance would uh
increase
I okay just as a person who was you know
kind of sort of in this I would expect
the answer to be yes um I know in
reality once Senate Bill 228 passed um
and the compromise there because the
trial lawyers um wanted a requirement in
law that Pas carried appropriate medical
malpractice insurance Pas are the only
provider a healthc care provider in the
state where it's required by law that
they carry malpractice insurance no
other provider is required by that law
so that was part of the compromise of
moving 228 forward was to have that
requirement placed upon Pas and only Pas
and of course and so Pas uh saw their
malpractice insurance after 220 uh was
was passed it may be a coincidence but
uh we have heard that uh malpractice
insurance rates for Pas have have
skyrocketed since the passage of just
that bill all right thank
you lovely representative
Shu thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question can you tell us um
currently are Pas allowed to prescribe
opiates and if so how does that process
work yes they are and they're subject uh
the same as an NP or uh any other
provider that can prescribe those medic
those medications and they're subject to
the same federal and state laws and
regulations along those lines and it's
under their own
signature yes that's correct
representative representative manuti
thank you madam chair how does this uh
signature requirement if that is removed
for Pas how does the reimbursement from
the insurance will that change uh thank
you for the question uh pas are uh they
are
reimbursed directly for the care they
provide so they don't go through um that
Doctor Who's on that piece of paper um I
I would I would note
um and you you this there was a point I
I forgot to mention if there was one
change and I haven't really had a chance
to look at the amendment if there was
one change the Pas would suggest to this
bill um if again a bill that was not
brought forth at our request is that we
think it's responsible that there should
be a collaboration agreement uh for a
period of time once a PA comes out of
school and begins to practice uh or I
would say not you know at regardless of
their age I mean a lot of times they're
younger you know in their early 20s but
we think a period of time with a
collaboration agreement would be
appropriate uh I mentioned Massachusetts
they have a bill pending that would have
2,000 hours that's the equivalent of a
year um again no other provider would
have that requirement but we do we but
Pas feel like it would be responsible to
have uh maybe a 2,000 hour requirement
uh with a collaboration agreement and
then after the 2,000 hours that that
collaboration agreement would no longer
be
necessary thank you representative Cota
has a question yes I just read that
statute and it does say that um the
collaboration agreement M um means that
the physician is is available for any
type of question that the phys physician
assistant may have and you didn't
mention that in your description so it
does
provide on a consistent basis the
availability of that physician which I
think is needs to be pointed out is that
correct uh you're correct and if and I
was if I was attempting to actually make
that point if I didn't clearly then I I
apologize and that's an that's a very
important Point uh representative to
raise and I apologize for not making it
clear or thank you um the point I was
trying to make was it doesn't it's it
doesn't have to be the doctor that signs
that that collaboration agreement who
was available either in person or
electronically it has to be a member of
The healthc Care team on which that pa
uh Works performs practices medicine so
there does have to be a physician
available either in person or
electronically uh for consultation
whenever a PA is practicing medicine and
that is set forth in this in the statute
that that you mentioned and if I wasn't
a clear again I
apologize represent Simon thank you
madam chair uh thank you for taking my
question um I'm I'm just trying to parse
out the discrepancy between nurse
practitioners and phys Physicians
assistants um you had mentioned in your
testimony development over time uh
physicians assistant had actually been
an assistant to a physician so this kind
of collaboration agreement would make
sense because the physician was actually
responsible to oversee the work of the
physician's assistance at at that time I
would assume and make sure that they're
doing their work appropriately um we're
talking about whether we have a need for
this collaboration agreement for
physician's assistance still or not in
its current form uh I guess my question
what I'm trying to figure out is is
there a difference in the scope of
practice substant IAL enough that a
nurse practitioner doesn't need this um
and there doesn't seem to be a concern
of instituting one even for a year for
them but we still need to maintain it
for a physician's assistant do we have
any kind of um data that would
demonstrate uh increased safety for
patient care that results from these
agreements uh these collaborative
agreements between a physician assistant
and the physician
um I guess yeah I'm just trying to kind
of parse that out could you help me
thank you for the question uh so I I
think I believe the short answer to your
question is no um The
NPS uh there was a time when NPS had to
have some the equivalent of a
supervisory agreement or collaboration
agreement as we say now uh and I believe
in 28 States including New Hampshire
that is no longer required um so but in
terms of the the scope of practice
they're both mid-level providers the
scope of practice is ultimately
determined by the
employer experience training and whatnot
but again the short answer is no there
is no real I guess there is no
difference the Train the training in you
know their education and the clinical
training as part of their education is
different Pas is more robust both
classroom and clinical but uh if you
take two a 20-year PA and a 20 year NP
uh you know I don't think there's much
difference follow did I did you I I feel
like there was another part of your
question I may not have answered yeah no
and I actually think I can clarify after
your answer I think I can clarify my
question um I'm I'm really trying to get
to the question of patient safety oh
that's right yes so whereas a nurse
practitioner doesn't need this agreement
and a physician's assistant does need
this agreement um do we have any
indication that uh there are poorer
outcomes for people who go to nurse
practitioners then go to Physicians
assistants because they don't have this
collaboration oversight agreement in
place no I don't believe there's any
data that would suggest one way or the
other okay thank you thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you madam chair Ava
Hawks
good I think it's still morning good
morning Madame chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Ava
Hawks and I am here representing the New
Hampshire Medical Society um and we are
opposed to House Bill 1222 at the onset
I just want to provide a few clarifiers
after um listening to some of the
testimony and the introduction from the
prime sponsor and co-sponsor um I will
so I want to share a couple things at
the onset so I will note my testimony is
not catered to or around the amendment I
just became aware of the amendment this
morning got to glance at it briefly
before I passed it off to somebody else
so they had a chance to review it um so
my amend my testimony is speaking to the
bill as introduced secondarily my
testimony is not catered to the history
of um NPS in our state and their ability
to practice because that as my I
understand it is not the scope of this
bill as introduced or is amended so my
testimony does not speak to that history
so I just wanted to make that clear I
also want to thank the prime sponsor for
being responsive to his constituents and
their desire to increase access to care
in his area in a previous life be before
joining the medical society I worked for
the legislature and had the opportunity
to staff a senator who represented uh
Littleton in his district so I I
understand the the severe access to care
issue in the North Country um so anyways
I will get into my testimony and thank
you so the relationship between
Physicians and physician assistance is a
valued one as the two work
collaboratively as part of a medical
team to provide effective patient-
centered health care and while Pas are
important members of the healthcare
ecosystem providing needed supports
during a time where the entire Health
Care system is struggling with a
Workforce shortage and significant
burnout the extent of the education
training and licensing requirements of
Pas today would not allow for their
independent practice to be conducted
safely effectively without Excuse Me
Miss Ox you don't really need to read
your testimony we've got it here if you
just give us the highlights yes you got
it Madam chair um I will stop here and
just add I know that
um I'll keep going so just for
perspective 46 set of all um states
require physician supervision or
collaboration of physician assistants in
nearly all 50 states physicians
assistant scope of practice is
determined with a supervising or
collaborating physician I am glad my
friend uh and uh Dave czy mentioned that
uh we in sential 228 a few years back
worked to really redefine New Hampshire
statute to speak to how collaborative um
the relationship is with Physicians and
PAs in our State I will also say with
all due respect to my friend Dave kzy I
I I'm sure our our members and the
Physicians of the state would not look
at the collaborative agreement with Pas
is just as simple we signed a piece of
paper we're not going to have any
contact with this pa uh we would
respectfully disagree on that but I I I
understand that he has you know
firsthand stories Etc but I wanted to
make that clear um I will go back to
just reading just to note a statistic to
make sure I get it right but the AMA the
the largest and only National
Association that convenes 190 State and
Specialty medical societies strongly
opposes legislation such as this and in
December they released an article which
I've um added the link should folks want
to look into that further in this
testimony that speaks to the risk the
concerns about risk to Patient Care um
should states begin to allow the inde
independent practice of Pas and one
quote that I pulled and included that I
thought was really important uh resulted
in um some research conducted with
physician assistant program medical
directors where 89% of them and 86% of
the program directors and
100% of past presidents of the PA
education accreditation Association the
only National Organization representing
PA educational programs in the US um
says that their current curriculum does
not prepare graduates to practice
without a supervi supervisory or
collaborative relationship with a
physician those are their Folks at the
national level and this again was uh an
article dropped in December so not that
long ago and lastly you know I've
expressed for the committee before and
other legislation uh that speaks to this
issue or similar issues expanding scope
for certain folks the society's
membership is acutely aware of the
workforce shortage and the strains that
our healthc Care Professionals are
experiencing particularly after the
pandemic um and while we again
appreciate the prime sponsor and the
co-sponsor effort to address the access
to care issues in our state our
providers our members are not willing to
sacrifice or risk patient safety um by
progressing legislation such as this and
and I note in my testimony which I won't
read rebate them but the differences
between the Education and Training pH
between Physicians and physici assistant
I know there's been again a lot of
comparing of um NPS n pasas again I'm
not here to testify to that but what I
will say is we could also discuss the
the comparisons of PA's educational
training hours they need to put in to
Physicians and those are those are
different so I will wrap it up there and
I'm happy to take as many questions I
know there are other EXP experts here
for more technical ones thank you
representative leus uh thank you um I
know you said you're not here to testify
on it you said I'm not sure what you
said but it's you know arnps um however
I mean the comparison that's important
to me and I think others on the
committee is uh the difference where
aprns I think they're called versus the
Pas one has this requirement for the
collaboration agreement the other one
doesn't and so you know want to
understand what is it about either the
scope of practice or the training of the
two that differs so that it's um okay
for one not to have the requirement the
other to have it unless the medical
society believes APRN should have it too
I don't
know so I will try and determine the
question in that statement
um again I I'm happy to follow up with
the committee on our position on NP or
aprns but I didn't cater my testimony to
that conversation because this bill
isn't attempting to legislate how NPS or
APRN practice in our state you know I
will focus on the concerns that the
medical society our members nationally
and locally have about allowing PAs to
independently practice and my testimony
and additional information submitted by
doctors speak to the difference in the
Education and Training and I for the
sake of time I'm happy to submit
followup on what those differences are
holistically um and I I know previous
testifier had mentioned that there's not
a lot of founded data to suggest that
there are risks to safety I would point
to the statistic mentioned at the
beginning of my testimony where 46
states don't allow independent practice
so there's not going to be data because
46 other states have decided that that's
uh would risk patient safety and that's
I don't know if that answered your
question representative and if it didn't
I'm happy to follow up thank you and I
trust you will support the
subcommittee yes Madam chair
okay good this will be going to the
licensing subcommittee there are too
many issues hanging on this one is any
other questions represent Simon thank
you madam chair uh you mentioned that 46
States still require these agreements
and that the medical society has
concerns about uh patient safety without
them um do you have any data or
information or could you get any that
would demonstrate
increased uh an increase in poor
outcomes in the states that have removed
this agreement I believe it's was Utah
um Wyoming there was a couple of them
and whether or not in those States
removing those agreements has led to an
increase in poor outcomes for patient
care I am happy to reach out to some
experts and get back to the committee
thank
you yes representative man pudy thank
you madam chair quickly to go back on
the four that
do not require the collaborative
signature do they have the Pas have a
separate board in those States or um is
it still under the physician that is a
great question and I think that question
might be better suited to answer it more
eloquently by Dave czy if he is still
here what that looks like I'm not
familiar with how those four states
function but it's an important question
that I I feel like should be answered
yep thank you other questions thank you
very much thanks Madam chair does anyone
else wish to testify on House
Bill
1222 seeing none I will close the
hearing it is going to
subcommittee and I will open the hearing
on House Bill
1385 and call Representative papichi
Moher
thank you for the opportunity to address
the committee Madam chair members of the
committee I will uh do my best to keep
my testimony short because after all you
can only make so many long
speeches this um bill is the result of a
long project of cooperation between many
members some of which you see in the
sponsors list but we also reached out to
every every stakeholder involved that we
could get a hold of we researched what
other states have been doing on this
issue we've reached out to Veterans
organizations we had a lot of
conversations with the oplc we spoke
with other agencies we reached out to
the military really it was a team effort
and we had a you know Google Drive and I
if I show you how many documents we put
together for this um you know you'll
understand why sometimes it's hard to
stick to a couple of minutes to talk
about the result the intent of this bill
is to make make it easier for veterans
who already have met certain
requirements that are needed for
licensing to get those achievements
recognized and get their licensed in a
more streamlined and reduced cost
process and it's the right thing to do
both to recognize their service but also
to eliminate the need for any
duplicative uh you know training or um
you know unnecessary paperwork if you
look at the um
Financial note on the bill we were able
to craft it so that it should not
implementing this should not really
require any significant expenses there
shouldn't be a need for any new staff or
any new
Appropriations at least you know based
on the current estimates so we've we've
really
done as good of a job as we could to
keep this bill narrow in scope and try
to get the best bank for the buck as it
were
in a nutshell it requires U some an
state employee to be designated as the
program administrator and perform a list
of
Duties I would submit that some of them
we've had a hard time in the past
getting information and I know we had to
spend a lot of time for example trying
to research the various military
occupational codes and understand
exactly how they map to various licenses
it can be a pretty you know um
complicated topic so some of those are
required now to be maintained by the
oplc and kept up to date so you know
it's easier to um um make those
equivalences we listed specifically what
type of documents would be acceptable
how to map experience in the military
versus hours of experience in the
occupation and so on it's it's
reasonably straightforward I believe
that um you know this is a good bill and
obviously I'm available for any
questions the committee may have and I'm
sorry that you know nobody else from the
team was able to make it but this season
seems to be very crazy
busy I have a uh a question you look on
page
three lines
10 you're putting a mandate on insurance
carriers to
issue um occupational licensing
presumably liability
licensing regardless of what other
people who apply for that
insurance uh would be required to
do how do you think that's possible the
intent of that was to make sure that if
there are any requirements that are
applying to the civilians in order to
get licensed and the insurance companies
are basing their decision to issue
Insurance based on that examination
since this may wave some of those tests
or examinations we wanted to clarify the
language that obtaining the license is
what matters in the insurance being
issued rather than the insurer checking
for you know those specific exams being
taken it is just meant as a way to
address that potential snag in getting
an insurance if the insurance rules have
not been
updated thank you are there any other
questions represent
broa so I believe that and maybe I'm
misunderstanding the bill but I believe
that we already have reciprocity
between the
military and New Hampshire so how does
this enhance
that the intent of this is to streamline
the existing um recognition it is
basically the reci I don't know if I
would use the word reciprocity but the
recognition of the military training
that New Hampshire is offering exists
there are a couple of other chapters
that do this the intent is to make this
a bit more extensive and to add
additional Clarity and create a few
other um requirements for the U veterans
to receive prompt you know consideration
and again to avoid unnecessary
duplicative effort so we do not try to
change what already is there we want to
add a little bit to it leaving that in
place and building on
it would it be uh fair to say that what
you want is the Department of Veterans
Affairs to untangle the military
experience codes to help someone who's
applying for a license it is one of the
goals of the bill that's why on page two
we have specific language on that on
page two in uh lines nine and 10 and in
the general area this is one part where
we heard that people are really having a
hard time navigating it and it's not
just the veterans sometimes it is the
people on the oplc that are you know
getting confused honestly when you
research those military codes you got to
remember they also vary by Branch they
vary by specialization I understand
three of them so yes yes we we are
trying to simplify and organize that
information thank you represent vus
thank you so yeah correct me if I'm
wrong but it looks as though um a large
part of this is um is setting up this
sort of advisory thing to
uh help as you said both the veterans
and oplc understand the equivalence or
not um between the two and another the
the insurance thing is there is there
anything in here that requires oplc
itself to do
anything well other than its normal
activities I it
but I think the best way to answer that
I I wouldn't call this advisory I would
say it's more of an operational
requirements on how certain things
should be processed it basically
requires a particular role to be
assigned to somebody and defines the
responsibilities for that role it's more
than advisory for example if a committee
if a board needs an extension they have
to ask for one from the V VP
Administration so it's a bit more than
advisory
but yes it is some of this stuff is
stuff that the oplc already does some of
it is not it is an addition and a also a
formal a more formal codification of
practices that the oplc already has but
it's not just that it also adds a little
bit to it followup followup so but
specifically um you know I may have
missed it but is there anything in here
that directs the oplc to do anything
which they're not currently required to
do in statute I'm not I think for me I
think the answer is no but I I want to
verify that that that's correct I I'm
not aware of a statute that for example
would address the requirement
requirement on the bottom of page two of
having a prioritizing an application and
issuing a license if warranted in 10
days of receipt and of the following
portion so it could also be honestly
that there are so many statute that it
must be somewhere where I don't know
about it but I'm not aware of any such
requirements so my my belief is that yes
we are also asking them to do stuff they
are not doing today but we did again
have multiple conversations with them
and they are not only comfortable with
what is being asked of them but they
basically concluded that it will not
require additional Appropriations at
this
time um okay thank you and other than
getting help somebody from LC okay we we
will hear from more
people thank you questions thank
you Kevin
Grady
thank you madam chair uh ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a 25y
year Air Force veteran and I'm also a
25-year resident of the town of hooks at
New Hampshire today I'm here on behalf
of the state veterans advisory committee
and since this is my first trip to see
you folks this uh go around uh for those
of you unfamiliar with what we do um
we're chartered by state RSA 115 colon
a-8 there are four Representative
members uh Senators Lang and birdell and
representatives Roy and mamila who are
also on our committee and there are 20
veteran service organizations that
represent our committee and these names
would be familiar to you be like the
Veterans of Foreign Wars the American
Legion I personally represent the uh air
and space forces Association on the
committee and one of the things that we
do is we look through all the bills
coming before you folks and we pick out
the ones that have veteran impact and
then we take a position on those bills
and then I come tell you what that
position is uh our members unanimously
do support this bill and especially
support the concept we'll be the first
people to readily admit to you that we
don't understand all the intricacies of
Licensing or oplc or we're hoping that
more people understand that than than we
do but the idea of streamlining this
process and and trying to give a veteran
or a veteran's spouse and there's a bill
in the Senate right right now C A bill
485 that's helping to speed up spouse
licensing uh as well what we're trying
to do and and New Hampshire has a great
reputation for being a veteran friendly
State we're trying to keep that up by
trying to remove some of the impediments
that somebody might have who's been in
the military for a while wants to settle
down and bring their family to New
Hampshire the idea that they can get an
occupational license if it's required
relatively quickly because of a program
like this we think is a good thing um
and the last thing that I just wanted to
say is it looks to me like as they've
looked at this at least currently as
it's drawn up the the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
can support this inhouse without any
additional Personnel uh needs at at
least at the current time so we do
unanimously support this I I think
Colonel Perry is is going to tell you
some things also from the DMF uh
standpoint here in a minute but subject
to your questions that's all I wanted to
tell tell you this
morning thank you I think we'll reserve
the questions for the
specialist thank you Douglas
AER no I didn't but I think it
will good morning Douglas sler how
office of professional licenser and
certification General Council uh the
office doesn't take a position on this
um a lot of my notes today are Technical
and then
there is one issue I would like to point
out um and then I might be able to
answer representative lakes's question
about the changes to uh I my first
concern is on page
one um that's section Roman numeral 4
lines 22 through 24 that that last line
as long as all other board application
criteria are meant I think that might be
encroaching upon RSA
31017 again because we're we're talking
about uh Lure by endorsement and
reciprocal
lure
um I have a it's not very important but
the bottom of page two line 37 it says
such application and issue a license if
warranted a simple language change shall
process the application if we decide to
move
forward uh and then on page
three which line was that last comment
it was line 37 on the on page to it's
just a language suggestion nothing
nothing of
importance and then on page three uh
line three middle of the middle of the
page there it says if the board must
gather further information from any
other office or agency in a in order to
process the application uh that should
probably be the office since we're the
ones that's a squishy one because we we
the office might be asking for that
information and then if it's an a
situation where we sent it to the board
they might be asking so I think whoever
is processing it but it's not
necessarily going to be the board every
time um same thing on line six and then
my my concern here is that so under 541
a29 the office when we receive an
application we have 30 days to review it
we notify the applicant of any def icies
in the application and then it says uh
not to exceed 60 days from a receipt of
initial application the language is a
little wonky but typically an
application is going to be processed 30
to 60 days uh what this does is it gives
us a 10-day limit my concern here is
that in order to extend that 10day limit
we would have to request and receive
written confirmation from this VAP
administrator So within our 10day period
if we were to submit that day8 they
didn't get back to us for three days the
oplc is out of compliance at that point
um just something I wanted to flag for
the committee and then something else to
consider the the last section section
three this changes the language of
332g 7A it would create a new thing if
the intent is to have this only apply to
the boards under the oplc it might just
be an amendment to 31016
um I know there's a there's a Senate
Bill currently where we've made a
similar suggestion and that has to do
with uh digital verification of lure it
wouldn't overlap here but kind of keep
it all in one place
31016 because uh
332g would apply to LC licenses and
professions outside of the
oplc for example the New Hampshire Bar
Association so um and then I well I
guess I guess people after me can speak
to some of the collaborative efforts
between the oplc and what we're doing
for
veterans okay thank you and I'm sure you
will be supporting the
subcommittee representative laus yeah
just a request and that is um you
mentioned various concerns and and
suggestions for the bill if you could
send that an email and also the
citations the RSA citations that you
mentioned I didn't get thank
you represent Vera hi I just want you to
clarify my understanding of the bill so
really this licensing this veteran
licensing acceleration program is going
to be managed and the administrator is
going to be managed by the department of
military Affairs correct and this and
this um these and most of the bill
really talks about what that
administrator and what that organization
is going to do so do you think that
anything within oplc is going to a
change as a result of this and um
because I don't see how what you're
doing now is going to differ this really
just talks about the program and the
administration of that program by the
military services is that right I I the
big change would
be they they would notify us that an
application is coming from VAP and then
we would have that 10 days to process
instead of the typical
541a
29 deadlines
so 10 days instead of 30
essentially and and also the need for a
response if the application is missing
something that I would you agree that's
the main part that affects the oplc
correct followup followup so is those 10
days vers versus 29
burdensome I suppose
that depends I I think I'm more on the
on the back end right like we're
striving to get our applications process
as soon as possible and we typically can
do them very quickly uh under the
current situation
though you know if we find a deficiency
in the
application we notify the individual and
then they have time to respond and this
would take that away and we would also
have to get permission from another
agency to even extend those deadlines
and I think those are sort of where my
concerns are are coming from um I mean
theoretically you could one would hope
there's a couple of couple of things
going on one we're trying
to uh with technology make the process
better so that applications are complete
when they come through the first time
which is something we hope to achieve
and then I you know if if this position
were to work out theoretically we would
be getting perfect applications every
time I can't guarantee that uh and it's
not within the office's
control but these are just that kind of
timeline it was sort of just something I
wanted to bring to your
attention thank you represent
gold thank you madam chair and and I
know this is going to committee so I
don't want to waste a lot of time on
this but I just wondered um if you've
had experience with the military and and
whether or not um dealing with the
Veterans office service Affairs have you
been has it been difficult to get a
response and get a timely response when
questions have come up and oplc needed
more
information I think that varies from ly
to leny some lenes are incredibly
responsive when we send that information
away other times the time limits expire
and we are forced to deny because they
never responded at all so it it varies
from Individual okay
y other questions thank you very much
Warren
Perry good good morning Madam CH Madam
chair members of the committee for the
for the record my name is Warren Perry
I'm the deputy agent general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services in that
role we support the National Guard the
Division of Community Based military
programs the division of veteran
services and the Veteran Cemetery the
department has doesn't oppose the bill
actually supports the bill but I will
tell you that in the licensing process
the Department's position is the
ultimate responsibility to issue the
license remains with the boards and oplc
so the department of military Affairs
and veteran services won't necessarily
be able to impact whether or not the the
board's decision with regard to licenses
what we will be able to do is advise
them on what training occurred in
whatever particular uh military
occupational specialty or Air Force code
is so that they could make that
determination I would also add that the
responsibility to substantiate any
training or experience rest with the
veteran not with the department so the
veteran will have to substantiate their
training we can only assist them with
getting records that might substantiate
their training helping the board
whatever the board is understand what
that training may have consisted of so
that they can get it right so again the
department will just generally be in an
advisory role here with regard to what
goes on so I I would also add that you
know in in response to some of the the
questions I've had or heard uh in
previous testimony which is are we
already doing some of these things and
the answer is we are um
110-b col 73 A and B uh that's the
Department's regulations I mean statutes
they require us to manage a military
skills waiver program and a military
test waiver program most notably it it
deals with Medics and truck drivers like
CDL truck drivers because truck drivers
is a really transferable skill if you
drove a truck in Iraq you could probably
drive a truck in New Hampshire right
so so those so those things are there
but there you know the the military
occupational Specialties and
understanding them are complicated
particularly when it comes to things
like Plumbing or electricians and those
kinds of that kind of experience that we
have going on so we we can help
understand and break down what training
or experience you might have gained in
those Specialties when you're in the
military and how they might app apply to
the board but again the board is going
to make that ultimate decision whether
or not to Grant the
license thank you um I'm sorry I have a
couple more things just before I don't
want to take all your time I know it's
close to lunch Madam chair I'll get
through it quickly I'm sorry uh we
didn't put a fiscal note on this because
we already have the the the
administrator who ad manages the uh the
military skills test waiver program
progr we think we can uh kind of roll
these responsibilities they're not that
not that significant into that position
you know if it if it comes later that it
we can't we'll ask for another position
as as we move forward and the other
thing I I would say is I heard the
question about are we are we cooperating
with oplc and we are we are really
linked with oplc in this regard so I
just want to I want to say that one of
the things that the executive director
uh Lindsay Courtney is doing is she's
led a contract so they can do some
administrative rules review in terms of
uh and I think you may be aware of this
uh you know how they can rework the
ministrative rules to to uh to manage uh
you know uh issuing licenses and one
part of that is
incorporating the understanding of
military skills and how they may apply
and we generally would recommend that
they use the American Council on
education and how they use that model
and how which they Grant college credit
for military experience and it's really
really mature really really defined and
we can kind of tap into that and get it
moving uh in the right direction so
we're all we already have a plan to have
input into that contract to make sure
that that's addressed and what's going
on so you know uh executive director
Courtney and I we we talk probably
weekly in terms of Licensing things that
going thank you very good representative
leus thank you um sorry for trying to
cut you off intend that uh just could
you repeat more slowly the uh RSA uh
site for the the current law on this yes
it's 110b colon 73 A and
B 110b you know 110-b colon 73 A and B
thank
you other
questions I don't see any others but I
I'm sure you will also help the
subcommittee thresh the whatever you
need Miss Madam
chair marvelous all right does anyone
else wish to testify on House Bill
1385 seeing none I will close the
hearing send the bill to the licensing
subcommittee and we are in recess until
p.m.
opening the hearing on House Bill 1131
and I call the prime sponsor
representative
Greg thank you Madame chairwoman and
committee and thank you all for all of
your work it's nice to be in this nice
big room so my bill on HB 1131 is just
adding something that I think was
probably back in the day you know
omitted with a reason but doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense now so we're
talking about um in section D so the
mental health
services and it's talking about people
that are really waiting on their um
their permanent license so they have a
conditional license similar to the last
bill I talked about so we're talking
about the conditional license period so
they've already gone through all their
schooling they've done all their work
they've been able to intern um while
they're getting their uh approval and
getting all of that done and there say
by the way as an intern uh they're able
to see about 20 patients a week
sometimes and So then whenever they
graduate and they're waiting on that
permanent license where they're able to
work under current statute statute only
lets you go to a like a state
institution or facility so I'm just
adding outpatient Private Practice to
that because currently they are able to
intern at an outpatient private practice
but then once they get their all their
schooling done and everything that stops
so we have a lack of like Continuum of
Care ha so then and it could take up to
2 years to get their permanent license
so if they're only able to then go to
state facilities to be able to work in
that period the state facilities can't
handle all of the interns so it's kind
of that one of these things with our
Mental Health Services where we're
trying to uh open up a bottleneck in
making sure that we have enough
providers thank you I have a couple of
questions that came out of a related
Bill House Bill 1413 sure I'll do my
best and if you could um the first one
is that these individuals M do not
require any sort of license at
all they could be conditionally licensed
but they don't need to be on that is
that your intent this is this you are
amending the exemptions from lure this
is
not this is not my intent my intent is
that they can still while they do not
have their full license but they have
their conditional license to be able to
continue at the outpatient Private
Practice where they've been doing their
internship thank you that would help a
lot because it came out in the hearing
for the other Bill sure that
um nonprofits were able to use this
exemption but for-profits weren't and
that's why we haven't done anything with
the other bill because we wanted to get
these two and work them together okay so
this is not for unlicensed practice
right not at all
okay thank you that's very important
other questions representa manuti thank
you madam chair currently when they do
the internship at the um government or
public uh facility are they is it a paid
or unpaid uh internship I would have to
defer that to someone that would know
more information I do not know about
that represent laus thank you so um as I
understand
it
um I think you said something about
their their still part of their
training um they could work at an
outpatient Private Practice place and
then uh after the Train's complete they
can't currently yes okay follow up
follow up all right so when they're
doing it for their training when they're
working in outpatient Private
Practice um is there any additional
supervision or whatever of what they're
doing than there would be um after
they've finished their education and
they were to do the same thing sure so
there is supervision when they're in
their internship and thank you for the
question there is also and this is kind
of that last feel I came and talked to
you all about that conditional license
there is a supervisor so even so when
they have their conditional license
there is still a supervisor until
they're fully licensed so that would be
I somebody else will answer that for
sure but from what I understand that
that's that supervisor can then continue
on with them the requirements for a full
license is a certain amount of
supervised practice and if I understand
correctly this exemption and the supervi
is intended to give them a license
for for them to charge while they are
performing the supervised practice yes
yes we're not looking to um limit any
you know or to um take shortcuts or
anything on their education or on their
work we're just we're looking to open
this up so that they can stay so that we
can have a Continuum of Care because
they've already been seeing like 20
patients a week um so that they can
continue that in their conditional
license period okay thank you
okay anyone else thank you very much
thank you so much for your
time Melbourne Moran
this better all right okay I really
should reconsider running for State Rep
again because I've been here more than
my last term uh but again melbourn Moran
Jr I'm a licensed independent clinical
social worker I'm owner and operator of
one or less therapeutic services in
ntional New Hampshire and outpatient
Private Practice I spoke uh before you
at the last hearing on the other uh
legislation I'm here in support of this
bill um just like representative Craig
said um it is
an a good idea in the sense with the
interns for example and I can break them
down and I can provide additional
information uh regarding the actual ins
and outs of how we practice uh
Psychotherapy in a private practice so I
uh my organization has a very good
relationship with Rivier University we
have uh numerous uh interns from from
Riv uh that come uh to do their
internship in other schools as well some
uh unite School social work uh as well
we have students from there and other
schools of social work so they would
come and complete their internship and
through the statute as it is now they
are exempt from needing a supervision
contract because they are a part of an
accredited program that allows them to
practice uh Psychotherapy under the
supervision of a field instructor like
myself or another qualified
independently licensed practitioner um
as you can see many folks want to stay
at that internship that they've just
built up a a great relationship with the
their hopefully potential new employer
and I've already have a good solid case
load typically around 20 clients or so
just like my represent had stated there
is uh often a gap there and uh in the
sense of that person graduates and full
stop we have to wait all their patients
have to stop receiving treatment because
they don't have a supervision contract
on file with the board of mental health
so otherwise they're already qualified
to provide that service they've been uh
through an accredited uh degree program
they have all the requirements to
provide the service they've been doing
it already unlicensed under the
supervision of a internship supervisor
by the way no contract in that sense has
to go to the board of mental health for
approval um but then they have to stop
the treatment of these um Pro uh these
folks seeking chronic mental health care
and as I said in the last testimony
sometimes that can take in one case four
months for one of my staff to uh get
that supervision contract approved so
for a business like my own I either lose
an employee or we have 20 patients that
we can't serve uh and not just we're
just talking about one intern we have
many interns um in that function the
other great thing about this bill is uh
like I discussed last time the the full
intent is to have someone contracted for
supervision through approved supervisor
with the board of mental health so they
can get the hours TOS their license but
things happen people leave agencies and
for a period of time that person under
the supervision contract if their
supervisor leaves or something horrible
happens to them they can't practice
because the it's void we have to get
another supervisor we have to get it
reapproved by the board of mental health
and then they can practice again that
only applies to out patient private
practice at a Community Mental Health
Center at an institution or another
nonprofit a freder qualified Health
Center that doesn't happen because
they're already exempt from this uh via
this legislation it's just good care to
allow uh private practices to be
included in this because the RSA clearly
states clinical supervision is being
provided by that agency and federal law
when it comes to billing uh for Medicare
Medicaid and other services require
pre-licensed professional to be under
the supervision of a licensed
professional we're not doing anything
that's already out of the norm I'm
licensed here in New Hampshire
Massachusetts and Washington State I
have an office in Massachusetts I'm
opening one in Washington state those
two states Washington and New Hampshire
no supervision agreement exists you have
a supervisor who who's supervising you
things change they might have to get
another supervisor and at the end of the
supervision you sign a form submit it
under pains and penalty of perjury and
then you take your test and get your
license this is a very odd thing the
supervision piece in the state of New
Hampshire no other state does it like
this and it interrupts Quality Health
Care uh to patients because we're the
only industry that's not exempt from
when there's a A disruption in this in
the clinical
supervision thank you I have a question
this statute requires clinical
supervision of Staff presumably
including the new hires how was that
different from the requirement to have a
supervision agreement thank you that's
an excellent question uh Madam
chairwoman the supervision agreement
only exists in the context of getting
approved hours that will count towards
lure right so the hours that will count
if that agreement has to change or is
not in in Force at the time those hours
won't count towards someone seeking
their hours they'll still have
independently licensed supervision
they'll still be signing off uh notes
have to be signed off by the supervisor
every single note has to be routed to
the supervisor and approved uh Medicare
just did reduce some of their uh
stringencies they are now allowing that
the the provider doesn't need to be
physically on site uh for the patient uh
to be seen um by the pre-licensed person
but when that supervision contract is
interrupted or not in place those hours
aren't counting they're still getting
clinical supervision but it's just not
going to count towards their
license
all right well I can see why this bill
is going to
subcommittee anyone else have a
question represent man py thank you
madam chair you mentioned that you have
an office in Massachusetts and you have
an office in New Hampshire how
distinctly different it is for you to
get interns locally in Massachusetts and
provide continuity versus internship in
New Hampshire thank you representative
that's also another great question uh in
our Massachusetts office that's not even
a question of concern uh because there's
no barrier uh that would exist in the
state of Massachusetts to prevent that
person from staying on uh and getting a
supervisor and working towards their uh
liur of independent um license and uh be
mindful of the outpatient practice just
like with any even the mental health
centers that person who's uh unlicensed
still has to meet criteria uh for
insurance companies to either to build
for their service they have to have an
accredited degree they have to have um
that supervisor like we just talked
about and it is the uh responsibility of
the agency to ensure that they meet the
criteria absent of these uh AG uh
supervision agreements because otherwise
you're committing fraud and if there's
an agency out there who wants to utilize
this for some Mal intent and not have a
qualified clinician that they're
breaking the law this is a Chang in the
law for people who want to do good and
follow it and not have to pause
treatment for their patients because of
a a blip that we got excluded um from
this
process thank you any
others thank you very much for your
testimony thank you and will John
dejoy
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is John
dejoy I'm representing the National
Association of Social Workers the New
Hampshire
chapter uh good afternoon uh for the
record Lyn Courier Stanley uh I'm the
executive director of the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter and live in
Penacook uh I've asked my client to join
me there are some questions that
committee members had asked that she is
in a position to answer if people would
like to uh more information on that uh I
rise today in support of house bill
11:31 and respectfully ask the committee
to consider a housekeeping Amendment
related to the topic of the bill
uh I'm sure you've all had one of those
days when I printed out 20 copies of the
proposed amendment this morning and left
them in my
office so I have emailed through the
committee um testimony submission link
the the proposed amendment for you folks
to look at and I'll go through it uh at
this point it's very straightforward as
I said it's housekeeping I understand
it's the kiss of death but it truly is
housekeeping so the
first uh change goes back to house bill
65 655 from last year it is in regards
to the investigation section 310
col9 specifically the subject matter
expert we spent a long time last year
working with PLC came up you'll recall
that several of my clients had concerns
about how subject matter expert was
determined in the bill uh we agreed to
language at the oplc and in some last
minute changes at the committee of
conference there was just a mixup it was
not a willful um uh attempt to change
the language it was a mixup so we're
here now asking that that be changed
back to what we had originally proposed
with oplc support I will be meeting with
Lindsay Courtney this week to go through
the language again she tells me it's
been a year she wants to make sure she
knows exactly what the language says so
we're go through the language again uh
but she is in support of the concept of
what we're trying to do uh it will the
appointment of subject matter experts
will remain with the director of the
oplc and the boards will set the
criteria of of where the oplc will look
for um
experts the second piece of the
amendment is in regards to the licensed
clinical social worker chapter 330 uh
a18 we just became aware recently that
the licensed clinical social worker is
the official statutory name for the
licensed independent clinical social
worker unfortunately all Professionals
in the state as well as the board and
many others refer to social workers as
licensed independent clinical social
workers
LCSW all this amendment is asking to do
is to put the statutory title and the um
uh normal usage title together and just
refer to as the licensed independent
clinical social worker and that relates
to the provisional um license as
well that is the extent of what this
housekeeping Amendment asks for you
folks to consider
and with that I will end my
testimony and if the chair would like um
some of the questions um Miss gar
Stanley could certainly
answer representative laus you have a
question yeah I'm just maybe a little
confused so and maybe you can help um it
sounds
like they're proposing um an amendment
on kind of related but different topics
to this bill that are not part of the
bill it we need to look at that
Amendment and see if it is actually
Germain it may or may not be but yes we
we need to examine it um and it will be
going to subcommittee because the the
content of House Bill 1413 overlaps with
this so we need to make sure we're not
making changes of one that are
contradicted and we can look at whether
that amendment is appropriate to one
bill or the other maybe whatever okay
thank you yep
indeed represent Manti thank you Madame
chair so this the Gap what currently
exists that the internships internist
can go to nonprofit and
uh governmental agency versus private
practice that Gap will be closed with
your
uh amendment that you're
proposing by changing the
title no thank you representative for
the question it it it has no bearing on
the original bill it's just since lure
for social workers started we've all
been lcsws those are the letters after
our name licensed independent clinical
social worker uh last year because in
statute it says licensed clinical social
worker we suddenly went to
LCSW as our
letters which created a lot of
confusion and uh and is this a new
license is does this have a different
scope the amendment basically is just
asking for our letters back so that we
can not have to update all of our
websites and business cards and all of
that uh because we've always been
licensed independent clinical social
workers it has no bearing on the
original and that's why it's probably
going to be a non- germine Amendment but
no
problem other
questions seeing n thank you very much
for your
testimony James
kleene all right thank you my name is
James D senior uh I just graduated from
for University with masters in social
work so this affects me right from the
GetGo um I work for one toess therapic
services from Melbourne Moran and um I
had this issue as soon as I graduated so
in Massachusetts there wasn't this
restriction so from the day I graduated
May 20th last year I could start working
all my hours counted towards my
licsw uh as a matter of fact the day I
graduated I could actually apply
and take the LCSW exam down in
Massachusetts which is licensed
certified social worker you can't do
that in New Hampshire it wasn't until
almost the end of August that I got
approved for supervisory hours through
uh the state of New Hampshire so that's
almost a four Monon Gap that I have to
wait to get my licsw here in the state
of New Hampshire so because of that
what's happening is a lot of individuals
Which social workers are there to
advocate for there's a lot of wait list
there's not enough clinicians there's
not enough um funds when you work at a
uh Mental Health Community Center so
those weight lists can be six to 12
months long and those individuals are
not getting the care they need uh what's
also happening is is a lot of the my
cohorts my co-workers they are leaving
the state because of some of these
things especially the new grads because
it's much easier to go to a different
state and get licens quicker and start
working immediately and start serving
the people that we are supposed to be
serving out there in in the long run
this is going to save a lot of money for
the state especially people that are on
state funded Medicaid or Medicare
because they're going to get Services a
lot better and it's just like a cut if
you treat a cut quickly you're probably
not going to incur any other issues but
like mental health the sooner it gets
addressed the easier it's going to be so
in the long run it's going to end up
saving money because if it doesn't get
addressed individuals can stop taking
care of themselves other issues will
come up and that's who we really are
there to try to serve are all those
individuals that need that assistance
when it comes to mental health um and I
know talking with other people you know
there's reasons why I went out of state
for my education um and a lot of my
other co-workers again they're talking
about and I know other people that have
gone out of state uh like Massachusetts
I could have gotten licensed to New York
the day I graduated but you can't do
that here in the state of New Hampshire
so again there is that Gap uh in mental
health it doesn't look at economic
status it doesn't look look at gender it
doesn't look at political parties and
all I can see from supporting this bill
is it's nothing but good can come from
this excuse me do I understand you
correctly to that you implied that there
is no supervised practice required in
New York you no you still have
supervised practice but the day you
graduate you can start uh you can start
your hours in other words you don't have
to wait an additional time so like right
now I'm delayed four months here in New
Hampshire versus in massach
I can be licensed as An Li quicker than
I can here in New Hampshire waiting for
that and I'll be honest the response
back from the board approving these
supervisions it's all over the place it
could take a couple weeks for some
people and it can take up to four months
for other people well I'm sorry you had
to suffer the longer period are there
any other
questions I don't see any so thank you
for your testimony all right thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
11:31 all right this will be going to
subcommittee uh there is some research
from our committee researcher on the
conditional
licensure and I'd like to put in the in
the record that there are approximately
750 unlicensed individuals working under
supervision at the moment um the intent
was to have conditional licenses for
these people but that is not yet
happened
so all right I will close the public
hearing
and and we have some time before our
next hearing which is at
1:45
no
145 am I wrong I'm wrong excuse me wait
15 more
minutes
committee envir um Edna committee for
the time to speak today on this uh this
important bill hb1
1526 uh I'm introducing this bill
relative to a conditional Veterinary
license for veterinarians educated in
other
countries hb1 1526 would authorize the
board of veterinary medicine to issue a
conditional license to a foreign
educated veterinarian currently in the
process process of obtaining an
educational commission for foreign
Veterinary graduates
certificate other known otherwise known
as the ECF VG who has completed all
steps of the ecfvg except the clinical
proficiency exam the
CPE if the veterinarian has proof of
legal immigration status in the United
States applied and is waiting to take
the CPE and has taken the CPE and is
awaiting results or pass the CPE
and has applied for the New Hampshire
examination and employment and
supervision by a New Hampshire licensed
veterinarian the veterinarian Workforce
shortage experienced across the country
is often highlighted in New Hampshire um
the news of has reported that an
estimated 620 licensed veterinarians in
the state are seeing increased demand
for services burn out after the pandemic
and turnover at a rate rate twice that
of medical Physicians veter Ians try
their best to accommodate owner needs
but appointments are booking months in
advance for wellness checkups and they
can barely keep up with emergency calls
as far as licensure fees go if a new
license type is developed I would
imagine that it would adhere to the
current $155 licensing fee specified in
administrative rule PLC
10002 and any additional licenses would
increase Revenue to the oplc fund in the
f note the oplc did state that the
administrative cost for this could be
absorbed into their
budget this bill most importantly will
help alleviate the veterinarian Staffing
shortage problem with the goal of
enhancing timely access to Professional
Veterinary Medicine and as chairman of
environment and agriculture committee I
know that proper care and Humane
treatment of dogs and cats and all of
our animals require regular veterinary
care we currently have a crisis going on
with that access to that care and I
would ask you now to call Dr CLA Lindo
to give her testimony next as she was
the constituent who prompted me to file
this bill she can give you more details
on the problems she is currently
encountering at her veterinarian clinic
and how this bill will help her and
other veterinarian clinics in New
Hampshire deal with their urgent
Staffing
shortages so thank you and I appreciate
your time and
listening thank you representative Aaron
I take it that means you won't be taking
questions well I can take a question I'd
be happy to take questions I'm not sure
I can answer them sufficiently um so I
would defer to uh the veterinarian who
is living in the trenches and dealing
with this issue okay Dr Lindo and
BR mkelly Raza y thank you
uh could your associate from The
Claremont Charleston Animal Hospital
join you I think it would save us some
uh some time
and thank
you um sorry I'm not a really good
public speaker so I apologize if I I
mumble um so my name is Dr Claire Marie
Lindo I am uh a veterinarian in
Charlestown New Hampshire I am a Cornell
grad from 1998 and have been a
veterinarian since then in uh
Charlestown um during the time I've
watched um for a decade and a half the
number of veterinarians in my area have
remained fairly stable and in the past
half a dozen years we've lost about half
the veterinarians in our area um at that
same time we've had more people move
into our area uh during covid as they
fled the cities and brought their pets
with them and more of our clientele
because they were home during the
pandemic all also uh increased the
number of pets that they adopted so our
case load has has probably doubled and
yet our Veterinary colleagues the number
of us has diminished by half and it's
it's an overwhelming burden and um as
representative Aaron mentioned that
there is getting to be a lot of burnout
in the veterinary field and we really
need some help um the reason that I had
wanted to um that I had asked
representative Aaron to introduce this
bill is because I can't affect how many
people are going to graduate from
Veterinary Schools um there uh
interestingly enough there are now 11
proposed new Veterinary Schools
um and so because creating a new
veterinary school is is not a small
undertaking um I can't stress enough
that obviously the shortage of
veterinarians is not projected to change
anytime soon if 11 organizations who
know about each other's plans are still
planning on moving ahead to make new
veterinaries colleges in the US it is a
a huge burden um additionally new
graduating veterinarians are very
concerned about work life balance which
is a wonderful thing but it means that
they're not putting in the same number
of hours as uh the older veterinarians
like myself so we need even more
veterinarians to fill that need um but I
can't have an impact on the number of
people who are going to graduate um but
what we could have an impact on is the
number of veterinarians who have already
graduated who are not licensed to
practice um there is a very good good
process for uh foreign trained
veterinarians uh who have graduated from
non-av accredited vet schools um to
become avma accredited and to be able to
apply for a license and that is a
fantastic program and I am not looking
to circumvent that in any way shape or
form I want those veterinarians that are
practicing next to me to be equally uh
capable uh and meet our us standards the
problem is that they're of the two
processes one of them that I would focus
on is that ECF program the last step in
that program is the clinical proficiency
examination is Frau with some
difficulties the the avma group that
oversees it is is underst staffed there
are only two places in the United States
that actually administer this program
the other steps in the ecfv process can
be completed by Foreign trained
veterinarians in the country that they
live in online or by mail but that last
process has to be done here in the
United States there are no uh uh foreign
sites to do that um those two sites in
the US can accommodate a little over 200
applicants per
year there are a number of interesting
statistics but one of the thing that's
the hardest is that of firsttime
candidates through that ECF process
there's a 75% failure rate which means
that it adds roughly 50 to 55
veterinarians to our Nationwide need one
veterinarian per state every year which
is not enough
um the bill as a side effect would help
us to train those foreign trained
Veterinary graduates so that they might
have a better pass rate of that which
would help alleviate a little of the
backup um but it would also uh by
allowing specifically the veterinarians
who have passed all of the steps
including the national Veterinary
licensing exam which is the third step
in the ECF process the same National
licensing exam that I had to take and
every other veterinarian in the country
had to take um after they've passed that
and the national uh licensing exam and
are waiting on the CPE um this bill
would allow them to practice with a
conditional license under the
supervision of a state licensed
veterinarian who can mentor them the
same way that I mentored a new graduate
from a US accredited veterinary school
to help her learn her surgical skills to
learn her Small Animal Medical skills it
would allow us to Mentor those foreign
trained graduates in that same way so
that when they take the CPE they could
pass that more quickly but in allowing
them to be mentored it would also allow
them to do some of the things that they
are capable of doing uh to help
alleviate some of the case load for me
which would mean that my clients and my
patients would have more timely
veterinary care because right now
they we're like like representative
Aaron said we're booking out months in
advance for routine care there are a lot
of people who we have a hard time
accommodating with urgencies and
emergencies more overflow goes to the
emergency hospitals the emergency
hospital near me is down to one
veterinarian per shift and they are
turning emergencies away we have had
them refer people back to us to see
emergencies there's not enough of us um
so if we could have people who could
even do some of the things that a fully
licensed veterinarian can do that would
be helpful like I said I'm not
interested in someone who is not
qualified doing this job I care about my
patients and my clients so I would not
as a New Hampshire licensed veterinarian
not be willing to let people do things
that I don't think they're qualified to
do because I don't want them to hurt my
patients and my clients so there's no
incentive to have people doing things
that they shouldn't be doing this is an
incentive to train people appropriately
and help them uh along the way um
unfortunately the process now is
extremely slow it is over a year wait
time to get to the CPE that 75% failure
rate is not helpful um if they fail they
have to restart the process all over
another year or more to wait to get
through to retake the sections that they
can't take so this bill would help us
like I said to have people working
temporarily as well as to help train
them but the pro provisions of the bill
would make sure that this doesn't have
people say oh I'll just come VI a
temporary or provisional or
conditionally licensed veterinarian and
I'll never bother taking the CPE the
bill requires that they be have applied
to take the CPE and be somewhere in that
process to eventually get their ecfg
certificate in order to continue doing
this
um and so I I think probably at this
point if anyone has any questions maybe
I can answer questions at this point
thank you I have one question do us
trained veterinarians have to take an
equ
exam so uh us trained so American
Veterinary Veterinary Medical
Association accredited veterinarians
still have to take the national the nor
sorry the North American Veterinary
licensing exam before you're allowed to
practice that same nav is what is the
third step in the ecfg process it is
exactly the same test so that they both
have to take a test yes but a someone
who was not educated in this country
needs to take a practical exam yes so in
the US um going through your fourth year
of clinical rotations you have uh the um
Veterinary professors who are monitoring
your proficiency during those clinical
rotations um the other process the pave
process involves those foreign trained
veterinarians going through a year of
clinical rotations with those fourthe
Veterinary students as the alternative
to taking the clinical proficiency exam
so the clinical proficiency exam is uh a
means of having an equivalent to or an
alternative to that fourth year of
clinical rotations where you have an
observed uh period of of your
skills thank you represent leus thank
you so you um believe you said that
there was a year wait for the CPE is
that before you can start it or is that
you said that a CPE that process took a
year or is it a year
so when you apply for the CPE there is
over a year weight time to get a seat
just to get a slot just to get a slot um
that to be able to sit for the exam uh
in terms of they will notify
you their wait time is supposed to be a
month or so it seems like it's a little
bit longer than that but about a year
before you can actually get to take the
exam um you are required to take one of
the first spots that's open to you um if
you can't sorry you go back to the end
of the line and you forfeit your over
$7,000 fee that you applied it is
non-transferable non-refundable if you
can't take those dates uh if you have a
medical emergency sorry too bad you go
back to the end of the line followup
follow up just trying to be clear you
said you sit for an exam but also that
the uh the
Practical is the Practical the CP the
Practical or is that something it is the
exam the clinical proficiency exam so
it's a one year long exam no no it's I'm
sorry
the exam itself is a I believe three-day
seven part exam um that is uh
administered in two sites in the United
States but it from the time that you
apply for that until you can actually
take the exam is over a year weight
followup follow up yeah I'm trying to
understand the process so where in this
does fits the one-year clinical that
was the the alternative to the ecfvg
process for foreign trained
veterinarians to become eligible for
lure in any state in the US you can
either do the ECF process or you can do
the pave process the pave process has
that one year of clinical rotations the
ecfg process has the CPE followup
hopefully so how long does the
ecfg pro what is that process and how
long does it take so the first process
there are four step steps the first
process is um registering it is and I
apologize let me just grab my notes to
make sure that I don't make any mistakes
registering proof of graduation uh from
a Veterinary College and verifying their
Veterinary college credentials the
second step is assessing their English
language uh abilities the third step is
assessing their basic and clinical
veterinary science knowledge which is
passing that nav exam the same as
American veterinarians and then the
fourth is the Hands-On clinical
Veterinary skills which is that CPE so
those first steps um depend on how
quickly they are able to have the
initial information usually it has to be
notorized all of that is checked by the
ECF process their committee um but I
believe that it is a several year
process to get everything told from from
start to finish um the ECF process is a
several year process at this point
followup followup so that's just the E
ECF FG VG process and then the cpes
after that is am I understanding
correctly I think within that couple
year process is the CP the whole thing
yeah the whole thing all right thank
you represent Manti thank you Madame
chair so with the alternative outside of
the country they can do step one two and
three process correct if they follow up
with
that uh the
clinical practicum and the cpg
exam can has to be in person here in
country in the country in the US okay
one more follow follow up thank you so
this applies for both small animals and
large animals yes it
does sorry so you said that a a foreign
veterinarian could also take the final
year of clinical
rotations that would I presume involve
paying tuition to a vinary school if
they could get accepted correct if they
can get accepted there are not many
seats when I was going through clinical
rotations we had four or five foreign
trained veterinarians who were part of
our class of 80 added to our class of of
80 yes um do you know if foreign
veterinarian
schools have clinical rotations
included I don't know and I think that's
part of the reason that they may or may
not be avma accredited did the avma
accreditation means that they meet the
standards of our us accredited
veterinary schools and if they don't
have that then they don't meet
those right thank
you I don't see any other questions
thank you for your
testimony um I do have a copy of what I
had originally prepared because I wasn't
sure how much or little information you
wanted and so it's being passed out now
thank you all for your time thank thank
you Douglas
aack good afternoon Douglas ster general
counsel oplc uh the office doesn't take
a position on this bill but I just
wanted to point out a few um things that
sort of popped out concerns we had uh L
three the board May issue the
conditional license that's I think
everybody could come up here and testify
on my behalf at this point um there's a
line in here that says uh it's on line
five on the condition that the
veterinarian has legal immigration
status in the US and verifiable Status
information we don't collect immigration
status on any application in the office
we collect Social Security numbers or
tax identification numbers because we
have statutory Authority tied to child
support issues um if we didn't have that
statutory Authority we wouldn't even ask
those questions I just wanted to flag
that we do not ask that status um
there's a word on line eight it says or
has passed the
CP and has applied to it says write the
New Hampshire examination I want to make
sure that means
take the
examination um and then the last well
line 10 into 11 a conditional license
may be summarily revoked by a majority
vote of the board there might be some
due process issues there 541 if we're
going to take um somebody's license away
we have to give them notice opportunity
to be heard they have to have violated
either a statute or a rule but there has
to come from some Authority so I just
wanted to flag that for the committee um
and I'm happy to field any
questions is Simon thank you madam chair
I'm just trying to remind myself
conditional licensing as we've put it in
statute is that always two years or is
that
negotiable that's a good question so my
understanding what I'm familiar with
with u conditional licing
is
usually I can look further into this but
my experience with it is it's a way to
get somebody into the workforce quicker
than they would otherwise so the example
that comes to mind is maybe a nurse who
can start working under supervis maybe
under supervision who can start working
before we have the results of the
criminal background checkin which could
take 90 days so instead of making them
wait the 90 days they work pending the
outcome of those results they either be
get fully licensed or don't have a
license anymore I suppose after notice
and opportunity to be heard and mental
health the conditional license is two
years because it covers the two-year
supervised uh experience
requirement follow well maybe more to
you than to Mr aerop but um the just
because this process is so long and
involved um was the main reason I was
asking the question uh whether or not
there's typically something a standard
and statute that we've been using
because it seems like it's typically a
two-year process with the other things
that we've written and that might be
difficult at times with this a it would
be appropriate for us to add
a span for the maximum length of the
conditional
license two years is probably right
thank you and representative to your
point to under RSA 3108 the licenses
terms under LLC are two years I I was I
was imagining this would happen sooner
than that two-year period and would get
somebody on to full lure but I suppose
if you issued a conditional license they
hadn't met their criteria in two years
that would have to be renewed if
possible yeah and my assumption would be
that you could get it renewed but I just
wasn't it's not specified and I wasn't
sure if that was couldn't remember if we
had specified it more clearly in law
already or not
so okay Roby and then L thank you madam
chair um is you said the line five with
the IM uh legal immigrant status in
United States you said you verify Social
Security and tax ID number corre and
uh I'm not a lawyer but those are only
if you are legal is when you get those
if you're not you don't get it so that
would come as so the question is do the
things you
verify legal stat I don't think you need
to be a citizen to or even be in the
country to get attx ID
number so for example we have
accountants who do not live in the
country they get lure in New Hampshire
because they have a tax ID number they
could be doing business they can pay
taxes but they're not citizens they're
not immigrants they don't live here they
just do work for people in New Hampshire
so I don't know their status and I
wouldn't
ask and I would say that it's probably
not appropriate for us to ask the PLC to
to enforce immigration
laws look the employer the employer
would be the one who'd be responsible
correct anyone else have a question
represent leas that's right y um so you
mentioned two or three issues with this
because you sent email with those and in
particular on the last statement about
revoking the licenses uh if you could
have some more appropriate language for
it
I can do that yes
sir
right any other
questions okay thank you very much we
will
uh and I believe this will be going to
licensing subc commmittee as
well all
right
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1526 ah
yes yes yes I recognized
him all
right you have to the
buttone there you go thank you for the
record I'm Jay finy and I come from the
town of aworth and had been a former
member it seems that aworth breeds uh
chairman of the environment agriculture
committee but I was a former chair of
the environment and agriculture
committee and then after that I had
served uh for the Farm Service Agency
USDA one of the things that's overlooked
in this and I think it's a very valuable
thing to consider is that this may help
with an influx of what I call large
animal vets as you know right now the
state of New Hampshire has a dir of
large animal vets and quite frankly it
was 15 years ago when I first started at
the Farm Service Agency and we had a dir
of large animal vets then so I would
only encourage this committee to
consider this bill as uh favorable and
vote in favor of it and thank you very
much thank you I'll be very
brief are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony anyone
else all right seeing none I will close
the hearing and House Bill 1526 is going
to sub
committee and tomorrow we have an
executive session to vote on all of our
early
bills and I would expect people who are
going to be making motions to have their
commit
reports ready for use because I'm not
going to let you go home until you uh
turn in your committee report if you
don't I'll write it for
you and I won't necessarily agree with
you so please I will see you all
tomorrow and we hope we'll get this all
done
properly